you
and uh
just remind me the subcommittees are not
youtubed right
or they're not
nope
nope i got enough sound bites to to last
you
all right
so it being 10 o'clock i'm opening the
hearing on house bill 1274 and i call
yes
excuse me representative grota if you'd
mind taking notes representative scitec
welcome back we missed you
well good morning madam chair and good
morning to the committee
for the record my name is karen ebel i
represent merrimack district five which
is new london and newbury
and i'm here this morning to introduce
hb 1274 which would establish a study
committee to review the solid waste
practices of our state
agencies
i think at this point everybody has
heard quite a bit about the solid waste
situation in the state of new hampshire
and how many of the states in our region
are really making a lot of advancements
and trying to divert
the amount of solid waste that's going
in into their landfills away into more
recycling or a reduction of use
i just as a starting point i wanted to
mention
that hb 1274 is based is virtually
identical to hb 1706 which is a bill
that i introduced in 2020
the passage was unanimously recommended
by this committee and the bill passed on
the house consent calendar
but along with other bills
during the covet days it was laid on the
table by the senate so it has passed the
house once unanimously
i think just by way of background
you may recall back in 2019 china
decided to stop taking a lot of our
solid waste and recycled goods
and that put the problem that we have
with our solid waste really in sharp
focus the towns in particular that uh
did single stream where you put all your
recycling into one bucket and it has to
be sorted were particularly hit because
a lot of that ultimately did end up
going to china and that stopped
so during that period that's when i
decided to introduce a bill to
alleged to create a legislative study
committee
the hb 617s recycling and solid waste
management committee
and we did
a lot of work in an eight week period we
had about 50 stakeholders
and we heard a lot about a lot of the
problems that our municipalities
and our businesses were having with
waste and really the effect on property
taxes overall
but among the stakeholders that came in
to speak with us was the department of
admin administrative services
and
we
did put together a really comprehensive
report on
our findings
but one of the
things that
i felt and the committee felt was that
we really didn't have adequate time to
delve more deeply into
how our executive branch how our state
agencies deal with their solid waste
there is a statute which i mentioned in
my
in my testimony rsa9 hyphen c
which relates to solid waste
and
the recycling programs in fact it's
entitled state government waste
reduction recycling and recycled
products purchase
and there's a whole chapter on
on solid waste and what the executive
branch does with it i also provided to
you in my testimony a memorandum that
was prepared by das in fact
amy farnham
i invited to be here today from das she
did write the memo and it gives a good
overview of the
of the program that's administered by
das
i i
understand that das is not planning on
before our hb 617 committee
and in the memorandum that amy prepared
is that although the statutes created a
recycling program the recycling program
is a centralized program
and much of the solid waste disposal and
mechanisms are done agency by agency so
it's a decentralized program and it's
very
challenging at times to sort of
coordinate both
both sides
the other thing and
i
have to say i haven't i mean that's why
we need a study committee i haven't
delved deeply into this either
is that
the the state
it does have a program whereby the um
recyclables that we have are sold and
that generates that goes into a
recycling fund and that fund is supposed
to support
further
solid waste diversion efforts
so
the hb 617 committee
had a variety of recommendations as i
noted but one of them was that das
should work with the legislature to
review and update state laws to reflect
current solid ch solid waste challenges
and opportunities and coordinate
disposal and recycling efforts and it
was and there's also a lba performance
audit of das statewide recycling program
and it's our
understanding and if i'm incorrect they
can they can correct me um that it's not
been fully complied with yet so we
thought maybe if we had a study
committee we could look at that more
deeply as well
um
so i'm here uh as in my capacity as the
former chair of the hb 617 study
committee and following up on its
recommendations in the introduction
of this bill
i'll just add
that
i think that solid waste has been a
pretty hot topic in the past year or so
especially with the proposal by casella
and between that and the findings of our
study committee
several bills have been introduced and
passed the house one was to
change our solid waste diversion goals
so that we now have a 25 cents 25
percent reduction
by 2030 goal and 45 percent reduction
goal by 2050 and i feel we all have a
great uh responsibility to do right by
our state and the executive branch
certainly is a generator of quite a bit
of um
trash and i think it's worth looking a
little bit more closely at at how it's
managed and i think it's a good
role for a legislative study committee
so on that basis um
i'd like to recommend passage of this
bill and i'd be more than happy to take
your questions
thank you i see we do have some
questions representative o'brien
thank you madam chair
thank you representative ebel for uh
and others for bringing this forward uh
as you may
know that i we're another hat and that's
vice president of the board of aldermen
in nashua and uh i'm on the board of uh
public works committee and we've done a
lot of work and this is one of the
questions that really is hitting us in
the forefront
in the example in the city of nashua um
we basically take what you know two bins
not single stream two bins
and that goes to the landfill only to be
carted off to somewhere else where we
can get a uh a tier weight of lower than
to put it into our landfill because our
landfill is coming to the end so we're
very guarded with this so i understand
the economics to it it's china that was
one of the things that was brought up
will this committee look into the
economics and try to ingrain some
homegrown use for these type of
recyclables so that
they have somewhere to go within this i
mean this could be a drivable
opportunity that
we're just peeling back the covers on
well thank you for your question
representative o'brien i have to say
that when we first started to dive into
this subject in the committee that i
chaired two years ago
it was an astonishing journey because
really this is an issue that touches
every single person in every single
i
one of the another recommendation of the
study committee was that we form a solid
waste working group
and
that bill also passed the
past the house it has now the working
group has now been convened and i also
chair that committee
and the topics that you're talking about
as far as economics
how to promote markets
just to really look at the solid waste
situation in new hampshire and also to
work with
des in the production of a long-range
solid waste plan which has not been done
since 2003 that's all topics that are
going to be covered by the solid waste
working group
i would say this
study committee will be more focused on
what the state itself does with its
waste meaning the state agencies that'll
necessarily get into economics i think
especially because
if you feel that the state in general
has a solid waste problem
the state itself should
ostensibly be a leader in some of the
concepts that it puts forward to deal
with that problem
and
you know one of the things i think we'll
be looking at is just the various uh
procurement
uh
um
requirements because one of the problems
with recyclables is that you have to
have a market for them and so um you
know just talking about toilet paper or
whatever you want to talk about if you
buy toilet paper or paper that's 50
recyclable your you do help to promote a
recyclable market so i don't know if
that completely answers your question
but i want to assure you that even
though like the situation in nash or
whatever wouldn't be quite the focus
it's definitely being analyzed as part
of the solid waste working group
it does thank you representative thank
you madam chair representative lekkis
thank you um yeah my concerns are are
similar to uh representative o'brien's
and that
i think the key is finding a way to
safely get rid of uh
trash at as low a cost as possible both
for the state and you know all the
municipalities and
so i was uh wondering if there's a
particular reason and i feel that's true
whether it's recycling not recycling
whatever the method is the key is what
is it costing and i was just wondering
why looking at that's not explicitly
included in the duties
of this proposed commission
um
i mean i think if you review the
policies the economics will definitely
come into it it's just
i mean
i have to say when we did the 617
committee one of the i mean if not the
main reason that i introduced it was
that the poor municipalities were really
getting hit very hard with an increase
in tipping fees
so um
you know i think the idea is to to
review some of this solid waste as a as
a commodity in a way
separate the parts out and sell them
for reuse and then you can bring more
money in i mean that's that's really
what it's all about and
you know if we can work with the state
itself to save money and sort of
coordinate the practices
um that i mentioned earlier
all in all i mean in the end it's
it's better for the environment but it
also should save all of us money and um
i just have to add here when we're
talking about money
and the state
our neighboring states are
really focusing
very strongly on the issue of solid
waste they're they're putting a lot of
practices into place to avoid
landfilling and in fact they're starting
to shut down their landfills and that
really directly affects the state of new
hampshire because our tipping fees are
less than massachusetts massachusetts i
think on average is 122
dollars per ton we average 80.
and when towns in massachusetts are
looking to save some money
they can look right across the border
and come to our
come to our landfills so we just have a
whole lot of things to look at and i was
just really concerned and our study
committee was concerned that we actually
hadn't looked at the executive branch
practices
thank you
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
so representative
uh
dover has a recycling
program of sorts
and so does portsmouth and i imagine
that virtually every other city does
so the question i have is i i wonder
whether you think that the public
especially in the cities has any idea of
the the reality that an awful lot of
this stuff is not getting recycled at
all it's going right in the landfills
representative schmidt that's a very
interesting question but it's not
relevant to state agencies well but the
point is that that
i'm very supportive of the bill because
i think that we're kidding ourselves if
we think that it's it's not going to get
dramatically worse
very quickly if we don't do something so
but i'm i i do wonder whether whether
the public i think there is a relevancy
madam share
because i think if if the public
understood it they would they would get
be get up in arms about the idea that
the effort that they're going to
and the the value that is inherent in
this stuff um is
is being trashed so
i think there is a connection with i'll
do respect madam chair
but i i'm supportive of the bill of
course thank you for connecting it
representative schmidt are there any
other questions
yes representative pearson thank you
madam chair thank you representative for
for coming here um
i uh i personally find landfills
abhorrent that's how we dump trash 100
years ago and
we should we shouldn't be having them at
all period my town the folks i represent
in derry
our landfill is tapped out we truck
everything out
but we have a
facility that was built for several
million dollars to separate our
recycling in the public works director
tells us that a lot of it because the
cost
benefit isn't there
they end up it just ends up getting
dumped we don't even recycle glass and
dairy because it's too expensive it gets
ground up and mixed into asphalt
so
looking at this from us from what you're
proposing at the state level in your
testimony you brought
that you passed passed out you provided
a state policy
right that already exists in reference
to
um
yes
you know the what the what the state
should be doing so there's a seems as
though we have a policy
um and on top of that there has been a
recent
committee that you've referred to
our our
hb617 study committee correct okay that
yeah actually the
the my
my point is is that with having a state
policy in in
that seems to be in place and having a
recent
committee already functioning
is it a little too soon to be convening
another one or you know we have 200
committees in the right now
is there an existing committee that this
can be
can be this mission can be brought to
rather than forming a 201st
committee that's a that's a very good
question um i chaired for two years a
committee on committees looking over all
these committees and recommending uh
repeal
but you know the primary
problem that we focused on is the
creation of committees that have an
unlimited life
term so i'm glad you asked the question
actually because i was going to
get into this because of this other hat
you know stud study committees um
legislative study committees they're
five people they're very short-term
and if you have people that are really
dedicated uh
to delving into a particular topic they
could really do great things
the recycling study committee that i did
we really we got very deep very fast we
had over 50 stakeholders but
as i mentioned
one of the things that we just really
didn't have time to get into adequately
was what the state does with its own
waste
we do have statutes in place it sounds
to me from the
from the
performance audit that it's been
difficult for the agency to really do as
much as it should be able to do
using those statutes the other thing i
would say is that the statutes haven't
really been reviewed since their um
introduction which if i read the
the the the uh notes correctly it's
probably 2008.
um
and again in our region a lot of states
are analyzing their own executive branch
practices to see if they can't do better
i mean we are we do now have a diversion
goal and i agree with you landfilling is
pretty abhorrent
i would argue that our state should help
our state agencies should
put together practices that help to
achieve those goals so i do think
that this committee
would be
worthwhile i can tell you that the solid
waste working group that i'm chairing
now there's about 20 people
i don't really think that we're going to
are there other questions from the
committee
okay seeing none thank you
representative
is there anyone else who wishes to
seeing none i'll close the public
hearing
all right it being 10 30 i'm opening the
hearing on house bill 1171 and i call
thank you madam chair and honorable
committee members as the prime sponsor i
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
to you today
house bill 1171 exempting certain niche
beauty services from licensure
requirements
for the record i am representative diane
power i represent the towns of brookline
and mason in hillsborough county
district 26.
this bill exempts certain niche beauty
services from occupational and shop
licensure requirements
niche beauty services are specialized
services that are limited in scope are
inherently safe and do not use involve
the use of potentially dangerous
chemicals or tools
they are primarily learned outside of
cosmetology schools and are commonly
practiced by regular people
every day in their homes
niche beauty services covered in this
bill include
blow dry styling of hair
eyelash extension application
makeup application and threading
the problem that this bill addresses is
that under current new hampshire law
individuals who desire to provide niche
beauty services to clients
must spend thousands of dollars to
attend cosmetology school
the average cosmetology program in new
hampshire
cost over 19 thousand dollars
they must also earn hundreds of
educational credit hours in new
hampshire 1500 educational hours are
required for cosmetology licensure
for
comparison an emt licensure requires a
minimum minimum of 150 educational hours
which is one-tenth of the cosmetology
requirement
and these individuals must pay a 104
dollar practical exam fee
and an 88 dollar written exam fee
and 30 dollars to obtain a new license
all of these expenses often lead to
financial debt in order to attend a
program to learn
many skills that a niche beauty provider
will unlikely use in their practice
clearly this is time consuming costly
and unnecessary
the solution that this bill provides is
straightforward
first
this bill defines the limited
scope of practice for niche beauty
services to include blow dry styling
eyelash extension application
makeup application
and threading second
this bill exempts these four specific
niche beauty services from individual
and facility license requirements
and third
this bill provides protections under the
consumer protection act
lastly i have an amendment to the bill
and and that is in the handouts that i
gave to you
the purpose of the amendment is to
properly align the type of services
provided under rsa
313-a
colon 25 roman
with the exemption of niche beauty
services from occupational licensure the
language in section 16 on page 2 lines
31-32 is replaced by the amendment
in conclusion
this bill removes the red tape for
individuals seeking to work in the niche
beauty industry
this bill creates
job opportunities in new hampshire by
exempting these niche beauty services
from licensure requirements and
this bill upholds
the current laws for the practice of
licensed barbering cosmetology and
aesthetic professionals
that concludes my bill introduction
madam chair i am happy to answer any
questions at this time
if you allow
thank you very much representative power
i will ask on behalf of representative
schmidt that you submit your written
testimony to the clerk for inclusion in
the bill file
are there any other questions for
representative power yes representative
schmidt
thank you madam chair and thank you for
asking my perennial question
but
i'm wondering
representative power
whether the current
cosmetology practitioners licensees and
so forth do they already provide
any or all of these services
thank you for the question
representative
so that would depend on the
services that a particular licensed
cosmetologist
chooses to provide
they're oftentimes licensed
cosmetologists
decide to specialize
in a certain
service for example hair extensions they
they
typically
you know will not
just solely focus on that
so additionally what i would say is
that it again it all depends
but to be clear
topics such as threading
in eyelash extensions it's not typically
found in the required cosmetology
curriculum
if a
individual would like to
provide those services to clients they
must
not must
they they will learn those skills
outside of the
curriculum
that they that they
take in cosmetology school it's an extra
step one follow-up madame pure so i i
kind of know what some of these services
are but i have no idea what threading is
i'm on the wrong side of the uh
dividing wall to uh to know that
okay so so in in general threading is
the it's the hair removal
by use of a cotton thread by which the
thread is
wrapped around the the individual hairs
and that is used to remove the hair
additionally on page two of the bill
language
lines eight through eleven
is um
a statutory definition of threading and
you you could refer to that thank you
representative
thank you representative power
when
when eyelash extensions are used
does it not involve glue
i'm over here okay
sorry
if you could see you're looking for me
so the question was
does eyelash extension application
involve the use of glue the answer is
that it does involve the use of an
adhesive
and the adhesive is applied to the
extension
away from the client
typically it it depends on the brand of
the eyelash
eyelash extension it
may be found in a pot on on a ring that
is placed on the
provider's
finger
the eyelash extension is the end of it
is dipped into to that and then it is
applied to the client's eye
alternatively
a glove
may
contain the adhesive similarly
procedures the same and additionally i
would add that
the preparation of the client
when doing eyelash extensions the the
the bottom eyelash is isolated and
draped
there is a gel pad and a sticker that
that keeps that eyelash
underneath the preparation and also the
upper eyelid is taped
taped so that
the eye
lid will not open so the eye is not
exposed the eyeball is not exposed it's
it's closed and
also the the glue has a setup time of a
half a second to a second
so there is in no very little chance
that that's
going to um be an issue and additionally
the application of the eyelash extension
it is applied to the eyelash and not to
follow up although that seems way too
much information but right i didn't mean
it to be so complicated i just wanted to
make sure that
would you not consider an adhesive a
chemical
that's the yes or no question if you
there are yes
a lot of things are chemical a solid a
solid substance is chemically based
thank you
yes represent pearson
madam chair and thank you for taking
[Music]
questions on a topic that i
am wholly
unexperienced in
but
my
what i am experiencing is my wife is a
retail pharmacy manager who sells all
kinds of things in the health and beauty
world
the particular
practices that you're outlining
in this piece of legislation
are any or all or some of these
something that people can buy
at the retail level and do themselves
that is correct for the most part that
that is in fact correct there are
different you know levels of of products
and lines that are offered but to answer
your question yes the these these are
practices and procedures that we all do
every day at home
and even our young you know children in
engage in in some of these act beauty
activities
i'm
well thank you
are there any other questions
representative marsh thank you madam
sharon thank you representative power
for taking my question
am i correct that the adhesive used for
eyelash extensions is cyanoacrylic
adhesive
um
i can't
i can't attest to that for sure when i
did
i don't know the chemical composition of
it offhand but i'd be happy to
look that up and additionally
when i did my research looking at
different lines of eyelash extensions
the adhesive is formulated differently
and i
i could look that up if you had a
particular
brand
that you were interested in we could
look that up and get back to you my my
particular concern relates to the fact
that in a former life i was once asked
to surgically reopen a child's eyes that
were glued shut with cyanogen so
are there any other questions
okay seeing none thank you for your
testimony representative power
yeah thank you madam chair
um i'm joe petrie i uh representative
joe petry actually
i represent stratfor 2 which is
farmington
to see you
and uh
got a few things to say about
this cosmetology business
uh
one in
in the 1950s
occupations were licensed
which is uh
pretty astounding in other words you
didn't really need much of a license to
another thing um
we're talking about money i believe
representative payer said that uh it
cost about nineteen thousand dollars to
get an education
for cosmetology
now
i actually ran across an article my
wife's a hairdresser she's been a
hairdresser since 1965.
and uh
what happened when we when they started
giving government loans
all right it became a cash cow for these
uh beauty schools
and this is
i mean it's
a matter of fact in new york they
actually brought some people to trial
and
when some went to jail
that's not very good new york speaking
of new york uh the
requirements there are a thousand hours
versus 1500 in new hampshire which which
has been mentioned
that's
you know it's it's a bit excessive uh
these beauty schools they actually
um
they do a lot of
obviously they got the kids are gonna
the people
the kids the students have got to
practice so it's a revenue stream also
because people come off the street and
they go to the beauty school and
that's that's pretty bad one other point
i wanted to make was
requirements all right my one like i
said my wife has been a hairdresser for
uh since 1965.
she
all right she she kept up her license i
mean and and sometimes you have a lapse
in license
and what
one time we you know because she missed
it she might miss it a couple enemies
not higher on a priority list i mean
she's
getting to be a young lady
she does my hair too i hope you like it
but
the fact is if you let it lapse you have
to go through all these requirements
again
you know under 313 a 11.
and that's that shouldn't be now so and
i think it's discretionary because
sometimes
she's done it and they said we'll just
pay the fee this time and that's that's
fine and the reason is
is because when you go to some beauty uh
supply places
you need to show a license
and
they will not sell the product to you if
you don't have a license
that's
that to me is you know it's important uh
you know her i mean you know she and she
does
you know if you can't read i mean that
that's the basic thing with cosmetology
you got to make sure that you read
the
the perm or the whatever and make sure
that it gets
you have it right because you can
obviously you can burn somebody's head
and whatever and that's
but do you need 1500 hours to do this
plus
some apprenticeship after that i mean
that's that's that's quite excessive
so
hopefully uh you'll
look
with good light on this bill and uh
thank you very much any questions
thank you representative
are there any questions for the
representative from the committee seeing
the chair calls drew
cline from the josiah bartlett center
i'm sorry if i get your last name wrong
it's
turn yeah you're gonna and for those of
you that are gonna testify you really
have to eat the microphone otherwise um
the folks on youtube are not gonna hear
you
pushing the button there we go i'd let
it go all right uh thank you i'm drew
klein from the just high bartlett center
for public policy we're in new
hampshire's free market think tank and
i'll try to sum up our um
analysis of this bill rather quickly we
think this bill would achieve two
positive goals where it to pass one is
that by creating separate legal
categories of niche beauty services that
don't require expensive time-consuming
and unnecessary licensure we can expect
this bill to lead to a flurry of
entrepreneurship in new hampshire and
i'm going to give you some examples
i don't know how many of you are
familiar with blow dry bars these are
you know a very hot beauty trend right
now it is a sort of a semi salon where
you can come in and
only get a wash shampoo blow dry a
couple of you know quick beauty services
they do not do haircuts it's not a
full-service salon so it's a very quick
short thing women use them a lot for
weddings going out on the weekends
special events that kind of thing
to my knowledge they're only two in new
hampshire right now
and one of the reasons is you have to
have a full cosmetology license to offer
these services and that is as a previous
speaker mentioned 1500 hours of training
massachusetts by the way requires only a
thousand hours of training to be a
cosmetologist we require 1500 hours of
training or 3 000 hours over two years
as
serving under a licensed cosmetologist
there's a massive amount of training
low much higher 30 percent higher 33
higher than massachusetts
you have to go through that training
just to open a blow drive bar
that would do shampoos and blow dries
some of them offer makeup application as
that level of licensure and
certification is just not necessary to
offer these niche beauty services all
the disputed services that are covered
in this bill
would now if this bill passes
be able to be provided without going
through that massive level of additional
training for services that these
providers would never offer
so if you open a niche beauty service
salon after the spill passes you would
not be allowed to provide the
higher level training services that a
cosmetology license requires
so by lowering that buried entry we
think you're going to see a lot more
entrepreneurship in new hampshire a lot
more small businesses pop up not just
blow dry salons but
all the other niche services makeup
application for example
so
and i'll give you another example of
another thing this bill does that hasn't
been talked about most states
have a list of exceptions to the
cosmetology license
for
theatrical
production and demonstration so if you
go to the macy's in the mall you see the
ladies there offering makeup
demonstrations they in new hampshire
have to have a cosmetology license
in 40 other states they do not
in vermont they do not
so every bordering state in new
hampshire
has exemptions for
some form of either demonstration of a
makeup product or theatrical television
studio
and modeling so you wouldn't have to
have a cosmetology license to put makeup
on at the palace theater
or
and this is a favorite pet peeve of mine
for the new hampshire primary when cnn
comes and all the network television
stations come in new hampshire the
people who put the makeup on there are
not exempted from having cosmetology
license so to put powder on
a state senator to do a tv hit for
c-span that person in new hampshire is
not exempted from the cosmetology
license in vermont they are
in massachusetts there's a special carve
out for demonstrators in maine their
exemption is almost identical to the one
in this bill so they carve out for
theater for demonstrations so just to
give you an example
if bernie sanders
were to join a theatrical production in
burlington vermont and get his makeup
put on he would not have to have a
cosmetologist do it
but if he were to come to new hampshire
and run for president again
and do a cnn hit from manchester he
would have to have a cosmetologist put
his powder on
i don't think there's anybody who could
justify this from a public health or
safety
standpoint so that's just one of the
things that this bill would clean up
right it would allow those exemptions
and we think that would be a good thing
so it would allow for entrepreneurship
it would allow for
more people to enter this profession uh
especially during the primary i don't
know how many of you do tv hits during
the primary but there's a shortage of
makeup
applicators during the primary and this
would
help
alleviate that it would also bring the
other
effect that we think this would have is
it would bring people out of the black
market
so
right now
to providing these services you have to
have a cosmetology license well what do
you think happens when you have this
barrier that's about a 20 000
um license because you have to go to
school for it and then you have to have
all those hours of training
people do it on the side
right to their friends and family in
their neighborhood they do these
services and that's outside it's kind of
an illicit market so
by removing those heavy license
requirements we think this would pull
that into the light and you'd have a lot
more people trying to open up salons and
do more legit businesses and that would
be a good thing for new hampshire
representative o'brien
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
klein for taking my question uh i hear
that you looked at this issue uh you uh
you said new hampshire think tank and
you said to his aunt before i can't even
say on some you know
business skills
can't get tongue tied at times but you
know what i mean
well that's good
but what i'm more focused with is the
work and i'll give you the
the focus that i'm talking about you
take somebody that did invest into
cosmetology school and graduated paid
all that money
now
tries to work in this type of business
would have to be working at a lower wage
so can you try to convince me that this
is not an attempt
to go against the education that some of
these people
really strive to get
and replace them with a low-grade single
focus type of worker i mean this seems
to be an anti-labor type of movement
that i'm seeing right now
i think you know i hear the question and
i um i don't see it that way and i think
that analysis is incorrect for a couple
of reasons for one is
this does not eliminate the cosmetology
license
that
remains a very valuable thing right so
if you want to offer a full service
salon you still have to get that
cosmetology license that is a separate
level of services and that is not going
to go away
so this bill doesn't take away
any service from the cosmetologist
cosmetologists can still offer
everything they offer now
um
all this bill does is take
a small subset of services like i said
that the low skilled services compared
to a full cosmetology license
and i just want that relative low skill
to be clear they're not entirely low
skilled but compared to a full
cosmetologist right so
um it's simple things like the sponsor
said so washing and blow drying hair
so state licensure exists to protect
public health and safety
if a particular service is lumped into a
bigger license and there is no public
health or safety need for that then the
state is doing the economy a disservice
because it is making people pay
um
a lot more
and go into a certain license uh to a
certain legislative professional for
something they don't need to right
that's licensed professional can still
do that service and if somebody values
that and wants that they can but just
for shampooing and hair cutting and
makeup application if they only want
those little things or eyebrow threading
right they can go to somebody else and
do it so it just it actually um
doesn't hurt the cosmetologist because
they can still do the full service but
it allows
other people particularly low-income
women who offer a lot of these type of
threading services um just like with
hair braiding
a few years ago
it really allows them
a way to get into the field and make a
living and that's really what it's about
thank you mr klein and thank you mr
chairman
thank you
what data do you have that
women who would
blow dry and wash and blow dry your hair
at one of these establishments
would provide
that service
at less money
than a bee salon
thank you i think that's a little bit of
a misnomer we're not saying that the
services would necessarily cost less i
don't know what they would cost that
depends on the market what we're saying
is that there's no public health or
safety justification
for having these services tied to a
cosmetology license because there's
they're not unsafe to offer without that
level of training
so
i i think you'd have to go look at what
the blow dry bars are charging versus
what the full salons are charging for
these services to figure that out um i'm
not saying necessarily it would reduce
the price it might you introduce more
competition
but
the bigger effect is that it's going to
open up entrepreneurship and opportunity
for people and that's what we're really
going to want to focus on
follow-up
thank you
mr klein if the services are already
available
at and establish i don't really i have
to say i don't really understand your
flurry of entrepreneurial activity
because
there is an established market
these products are available
at businesses now
and if there's an unknown price
advantage
where would this flurry of
entrepreneurial activity come from
by merely removing the license is that
what you're saying
there are two
there are different types of services
right so if you want to offer a full
service salon you have to pay 20 000
roughly for that cosmetology degree you
have to go to school you have to get the
training
what this bill would do
is say for this small subset of services
these niche services that are defined in
the bill shampooing conditioning
arranging curling blow drying right
you will not need a whole cosmetology
license for that so what that will do
is allow people to open more of these
small niche salons
i mean i just it's a it's a basic
economic concept if you lower
the cost of opening one of these salons
you're going to get more of those salons
follow
but you just told me a while back that
you can't tell me
that the price is going to be lower so
you see we're going around and around
and around you're saying okay the
license is costing a lot of money and
therefore people have to pay for that so
this is going to open up this this
market for people who don't have that
license but i can't so it's going to be
a lower cost but i can't tell you how
much lower the cost would be or it's
going to be you see you're true to
chasing your tail here
representative grota
my interpretation nope nope my
interpretation of what he's saying is
it's not necessarily a lower cost of the
consumer it's a lower cost for the
establishment of the business by the
folks that wish to perform the practice
that's correct it may end up being a
lower cost for the consumer i'm not able
to predict that right now but what
you're going to see is a lower cost to
start the business of vastly lower cars
to stock the business so you're going to
see more of these businesses pop up
theoretically you might see the costs
come down for these washington blow dry
services but i don't know that that'll
be the case we don't know how many
people are going to enter the field
thank you mr chair and thank you for
i'm hearing a lot about up and coming
salons and blow dry salons and bars
um there's so there must be
some statistics out there as to the
surrounding states that don't require
the licensing of these facilities
as to how many there are in
massachusetts vermont and maine do you
so i
the cosmetology license um i don't think
the surrounding states have done have
gone as far as this bill and separating
that out so what the surrounding states
do is they have the exemption for
makeup demonstration and for theatrical
production makeup application
but to my knowledge they still require
the full licensure
for all of the services that are under
here so the sponsor might know better
than me but um i think that's the case
so
what we're saying with this bill is
if you new hampshire would be
leading the pack in this field by
separating these things out these things
that aren't necessary to have a full
follow-up
but i want to go back to your
statement that these blow dry bars are
new and up and coming and that because
of new hampshire's law we only have two
where they are up and coming in other
states
and i want you to expand on that
tell me how
that data is confirmed and that this is
factual
so
they're really popular in big states
like florida new york and california
so
it's a fashionable trend right and so
those things lag
by the time you get up to new hampshire
so
what we're seeing is there is some
interest in new hampshire for opening
these things but so far right now i did
a google search for them and i found
only two in new hampshire
and what we're saying is
to open one you probably you might see a
few others open in new hampshire if we
don't change this but if we do change it
we're going to
really open it up in new hampshire and
make it much easier to open these types
of businesses and serve the customers
mr klein i actually have a question for
you in the
in your search of these types of
establishments in other areas
what do they typically refer to
themselves
as
as far as do they call themselves
names that are similar to what you would
find in a place that offers full
cosmetology
uh no they call themselves dry bars or
blow dry bars
the name of the business in fact there's
a chain
um
that's growing nationally and i think it
has the blow dry bars in its name but um
they distinguish themselves on purpose
from a regular salon they want the
customer to know before going in that
they only offer limited services
so none of these facil none of these
establishments
call themselves salons in their in their
titles that you've seen
yeah i mean i i haven't seen every
single one but um typically they call
themselves either blow dry bar or dry
bar
do i have any other questions from the
committee
representative o'brien
thank you mr chairman mr klein from what
you said there is a chain out there uh
is the chain off at that particular
business training has offered any
particular
interest in new hampshire and coming to
construct this particular build that we
are hearing today
i i can't speak to
the corporate chain i don't know
i know there's um
one of the at least one of the ones in
new hampshire i believe is a franchise
of a chain but i'm i'm i'm not gonna
that's okay if you don't have the answer
all right seeing no more questions thank
you sir for your testimony
representative rhodes you're in the hot
seat
thank you mr chairman thank you members
of the committee for hearing my
testimony today for the record my name
is jennifer rhodes i am the state
representative for cheshire district 15
representing winchester richmond
marlborough swansea and troy
i'm the co-sponsor of this bill for
several reasons one i moved to new
hampshire
however when i moved here i did have a
manager's license for cosmetology that
unfortunately was no longer valid the
reasons for that
was a lot of very unfortunate
medical
setbacks i had when i was pregnant with
my daughter
which unfortunately prevented me from
being able to continue working in the
industry
when i moved here however i did not lose
the skill that i had maintained that i
had retained and honed while i was
working in pennsylvania so let's say
that i move here
and the next bill that we are going to
hear talks about the responsibility
license or the requirements however it's
not necessarily easy just to transfer
your license so
having the skill that i had
i would say if i wanted to open up a dry
bar and i was not doing any chemical
services i'm not coloring anybody's hair
i am not perming anybody's hair i am
simply
offering
beauty type services which you can walk
into ulta and have done they often have
coupons for non-chemical services right
so that would have allowed me to move
here be able to
open up a business be able to give back
to my community bring some funds into
the state and help people feel better
about themselves
i would say it's pretty safe it's a
pretty safe assumption
that there are probably several people
that are sitting behind me that are
either enrolled in cosmetology school or
recently finished
that if they feel that they have the
skill
that it takes to do some of these
services and they don't have to pay
upwards of twenty five thousand dollars
in order to do that
let them
it's their reputation on the line
it's their financials that are on the
line
it's their livelihoods that are on the
whether or not they're going to testify
to that i don't know but i'm willing to
bet that there are several people out
there that parents might say
instead of twenty five thousand dollars
for this particular education i'm going
to invest in you opening up this dry bar
and see how it goes the fact of the
matter is things evolve over time that's
why we have policies for online media
right things change things aren't like
they were
then this is why all of these
beauties like alta offers beauty
services jcpenney offers beauty services
you can go into rite aid
and get false eyelashes you can be a
child and put them on your eyes with all
respect to what the representatives say
said having to perform a service to have
that taken care of that's very
unfortunate but i would have to say if
that was a child that did that that was
the parent's fault
does anyone have any questions for
seeing none thank you representative
the chair calls jessica
[Music]
petrois
from the institute for justice i hope i
got that right
did not i did not okay
patois poitras it all works
dear members of the executive department
and administrations committee thank you
for the opportunity to testify in
support of house bill 1171 which would
create more jobs and opportunities for
aspiring beauty entrepreneurs my name is
jessica patois and i'm legislative
counsel with the institute for justice
the ij is a national nonprofit
organization that advocates for
individual rights for nearly 30 years we
have helped reform beauty industry laws
in over 24 states through litigation and
legislative efforts
we have also published the first of its
kind report beauty school debt and
dropouts how cosmetology state or how
state cosmetology licensing fails
aspiring beauty workers which details
how state-mandated cosmetology programs
are roadblocks rather than stepping
stones for these professionals
new hampshire is ripe with opportunity
for beauty professionals but current
licensing laws shut people out of jobs
new hampshire requires bd professionals
to have one of the three big licenses
which i think you all are familiar with
the cosmetology barber barber's license
the manicurist license or an
esthetician's license
grouping all beauty services into one of
these three overbroad licenses does not
work for an industry that is based on
creativity and evolving techniques
outdated licensing requirements also
force beauty professionals into
time-consuming and costly traditional
cosmetology programs even though those
programs do not teach services that
these aspiring professionals would like
to offer
traditional cosmetology licensing laws
prevent niche beauty professionals from
entering the industry
as you all have heard today the beauty
services in this bill include blow dry
styling eyelash extension application
makeup application and threading
these services are different from the
big three licenses because they do not
use dangerous tools chemicals or dyes
they are limited in their scope of
practice and niche beauty professionals
train outside of cosmetology programs
through methods like private
certification and cultural exchange
most traditional cosmetology programs do
not teach beauties or do not teach niche
beauty services and if they do it's at a
very rudimentary level
even so aspiring niche beauty
professionals must complete the
traditional cosmetology program as a
requirement to licensure to provide
these services
the average student in new hampshire
takes out so you all have heard nineteen
thousand twenty thousand for overall
cosmetology school but 7 300
of federal student loan debt to complete
their first program and most students do
not graduate on time
in 2016 and 2017 only about 19 percent
of cosmetology students graduated on
time
their peers were forced to incur even
more debt to finish their training and
more time to finish that training
the result being that many niche beauty
professionals work in underground
economies where they where they face
exploitation or they continue to incur
insurmountable debt that also raises
costs for consumers without giving those
consumers any additional benefits
house bill 1171 is a solution for
aspiring beauty professionals based off
of proven methods of reform that have
created job opportunities
i encourage this committee to support
house bill 1171 for three reasons
first niche beauty services are safe
blow dry styling eyelash extension
application makeup application and
threading pose virtually no risk to
consumers
nationwide there have been very few
complaints filed with state boards of
cosmetology about health and safety
issues related to niche beauty services
when complaints are made they are
typically about the service provider's
licensure rather than health and safety
concerns
second most states already exempt niche
beauty services from license
requirements as you're all familiar with
and you've heard
new hampshire exempts hair braiding
which is a form of
hair styling from
from cosmetology requirements
over a dozen states exempt shampooing
from licensure requirements
five states exempt fully exempt blow dry
styling licensing requirements
10 states exempt makeup application from
cosmetology or esthetician licensing
requirements and most states also exempt
as as you've heard have exemptions for
theater television movie and radio
and modeling purposes or makeup counter
demonstrations
seven states exempt eyelash extension
professionals from licensing
requirements and finally 13 states
exempt threaters from cosmetology and
aesthetics licensing requirements
in several states threading also falls
into a regulatory gray area so the
number of states that do not require
threaders to be licensed is actually
greater than the states with full
exemptions
third house bill 1171 is a jobs bill
last year nearly half of american
companies reported labor shortages it's
time to take common sense and proven
measures to reduce known barriers to
entry
reducing licensing barriers for for
aspiring beauty professionals does just
that
for example after minnesota passed its
freelance hair and makeup licensing
reform there were nearly 1 000 bridal
hair and makeup artists who were free to
legitimately work without fear of
enforcement
additionally house bill 1171 mostly
benefits lower to middle income women
who do not have the time or money or
resources to attend a traditional
cosmetology program but they have the
training to provide those in-demand
services
finally this bill allows citizens across
the state to benefit from the wealth of
new talent and techniques that are
currently difficult to find in
conclusion i encourage this committee to
support house bill 1171 so that aspiring
beauty workers have every opportunity to
thrive in new hampshire thank you for
the opportunity to testify and i'm happy
to answer any questions that you only
have
thank you for your testimony
do we have any questions from the
committee
representative goalie thank you mr could
you just state your name again and who
you're with
jessica patois p-o-i-t-r-a-s
and they are located
we are headquartered in arlington
virginia but we have offices across the
country
thank you
do you have written testimony for the
i do not have it with me but i'm happy
to print it out and provide it before i
leave today
fantastic thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you
my last pink card will be mr conley
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee for holding this hearing today
uh just for the record my name's ross
connolly i'm the deputy state director
for americans for prosperity new
hampshire here today to voice our
support for hb 1171
i'll be briefed i i don't want to be
repetitive
in respect of the committee's time
but as we've heard this bill creates an
exemption
uh for the cosmetology license uh for
the uh for styling hair threading makeup
application
and eyelash extension application
all of these services are very low risk
to the consumer
since they do not involve cutting hair
coloring hair or chemically altering
hair in any way
currently
granite staters that are wishing to open
what's called a blow bar
in new hampshire would be required to go
through the same requirements as those
looking to open a salon or a barber shop
even though they only offer a very small
fraction
of those services and the least
complicated of those services uh this
bill would simply recognize that this
growing trend uh in cosmetology
obviously does not pose the same
level of of of uh threat to the consumer
or risk to the consumer
and they do not provide the same level
of services and therefore should not
have the same burden
of licensure
especially when those as i mentioned
those services do not pose a significant
risk to the public
even when it comes to to eyelash
extensions as we've heard uh this
process is the uh an adhesive is
pre-applied uh
and then the the uh obviously i'm no
expert in this i'll make that joke but i
i think uh when it comes to to that it
is not actually taught in the school
that's
that's required to get the license so if
you're getting training uh you're
requiring training to get a license for
a procedure that when you uh do acquire
that license and you you graduate from
the training and you've completed all
the steps you've received no training in
the procedure that you're looking to
provide
obviously that's that's uh ridiculous
and unnecessary and and we should uh
look at passing this bill to exempt
those services in those very specific uh
areas of cosmetology
um
these were the same reasons by the way i
i see some some committee members that
have been around for for quite some time
these were the same reasons that uh
that we exempted the hair braiding
license from cosmetology
back in 2017. it posed very little
threat to the public very little risk
and it allowed really low income
uh folks who may have been operating in
black markets to come out into the light
start a business create an industry i
can tell you uh just from from the hair
braiding license from 2017 a a a
woman by the name of sarah d'actor who's
a refugee in manchester uh was operating
uh in a gray area of the law beforehand
she now has a very successful shop in
manchester and has been able to to
provide their her kids to go into
private school she was able to move to
bedford really provide a a great thing
for her community so those are the the
folks that we're looking
to address with this niche beauty bill
is allowing them to to come out into the
open uh invest in their community and
and have this business uh so for those
reasons we urge the committee to move hb
1171 ought to pass
and i'd be
happy to take any questions if there are
any
do you have any questions from members
seeing none thank you and that will be
testify for those in the audience that
are unfamiliar if you're here for this
one or the next one um the procedure if
you wish to speak on a bill is to fill
out a pink card representative o'brien
is modeling those ever so eloquently
i apologize about not knowing the pink
slip
rule but i i really appreciate your time
and letting us have an opportunity to
speak my name is matt lambert
and i'm currently general manager at
empire beauty schools we've been open
for 58 years
and the founder norman langlois was a
world war ii veteran
who really enjoyed
seeing people enhance their lives
and
when he started the he started his
schools after he had opened up salons
from florida all the way up to maine
he was in the old um
uh malls the the bradleys and some of
those other big malls back in the day
and
his goal was to create more successful
stylists that knew about not only the
fundamentals but also guest service
and
one of the representatives was talking
about our clinics the reason we do have
clinics is so they can get practice
as anyone needs
everyone knows they need practice to get
better at their trade
and we do free haircuts for veterans
year round because of his world war ii
uh service
and our schools in laconia hooksett and
somersworth
have graduated a lot of successful
students so
i'm i'm a big believer before i came to
empire bus schools i was a regional
manager for regis corporation and i ran
salons from boston all the way up to
north conway and i got to witness a lot
of the things we're talking about
firsthand some of the
dangers in this industry and i know it's
they're not using um bleach and
chemicals chemicals to do
um
shampoos and blow drys
but
sanitation is a big part of our
education
so i just want to read a few things i
was thinking about when in talking to
you fine people licensure requirements
are in place for the public's protection
that's number one
requirements for licensure include
proper training in these services
application removal
product knowledge and how to handle
negative reactions
it is easy to spread infection if the
person doing the service does not have
the knowledge of infection control and
sanitation procedures
licensures ensures that the business
performing these services are inspected
in proper infection control procedures
are followed
public safety is the concern and during
the covet pandemic cosmetology is one of
the most regulated industries
because of the concern for the public
welfare as you remember on the news a
lot of the newscasters were going gray
and that was a major stress in a lot of
them
why are you why would we be lessening
this now with covert going on
licensure of the these procedures
ensures the board is able to take action
if harm to the client occurs
disciplinary action can take place if
there is a negligence if if it is buyer
beware what is the recourse the person
can continue to harm the public without
any consequences
and i heard one of the representatives
talk about um
jcpenney's and alta they are licensed in
those locations as well
and you know when talking about the 1500
hours i ran salons in massachusetts and
i can tell you the thousand hours they
had was not
was not enough because i could tell the
difference from a new hampshire
cosmetologist to a massachusetts
cosmetologist and back then they had to
have
work under someone for x amount of time
after they were licensed where in new
hampshire they're ready to go on their
own as soon as they graduate so
any questions and this by the way is
my some of our great students here from
our hooksett campus and they're getting
ready to graduate with their instructor
ms kelly
well thank you thank you for uh for
bringing them so that they can
experience a little bit of the process
of how
slow government works
any questions representative marsh
uh yes thank you mr chair and thank you
for taking my questions one of the
points made earlier uh was that there
was not a significant amount of training
in eyelash extensions in cosmetology
school uh can you tell us what sort of
training you do in your school for
yes thank you so in as far as eyelash
extensions it is a small portion of our
curriculum okay and we currently are
opening up an eyelash extension center
that we just we're wrapping up
completion on the on the building this
week actually
and they would have to come and get
certified in that just like in our
makeup we have a makeup school they have
to get certified in that but the
cosmetology aesthetics or barber license
helps them with sanitation practices
and they also look at skin disorders
and you know even when you're blow
drying someone's hair we we teach them
how to check their scalp
because if they have an infection they
have some something on their skin you
want to make sure you don't
harm that area
so as far as your question they do have
to get certified in that after they
graduate from our program but our
representative schuett
thank you mr chair
mr lambert you stated that
massachusetts law requires 1 000 hours
of training
but then after they complete that they
have to work under another licensee do
sorry it's been a few years since i've
been running since i ran massachusetts
salons but it was it was a year and they
stylist
[Music]
we heard testimony that
new york state also
requires a thousand hours do you know
anything about new york state do they
have to work under
a licensee after they complete that time
also i i apologize i don't know anything
about new york thank you
thank you mr chairman
uh mr amber thank you for being here uh
so
what is the current status of licensure
in
in the state of new hampshire in terms
of how many licensed cosmetologists we
have
paul are you asking for the number of
licensed cosmetologists in the state
that's what i'm asking yeah i don't have
that number
i know i know on average we graduate
over 300 a year
and this salon's opening up every every
day
uh
maybe i can ask a follow-up sure we'll
get at some of the information i'm
interested in so is is there a shortage
of
cosmetology positions or
services
in the state of new hampshire or our
schools and current practitioners are
they providing
uh the meeting the needs of the public
well that's a great question so
i went i graduated from umass amherst
and when i was there and i think
currently with unh and i heard the
common cash cow
these colleges are the cash cows
because there's not a lot of regulations
on them we are regulated to the
you wouldn't imagine the regulations we
have not just from the state the board
of education but also
nakas which is the national accrediting
career arts and sciences
and they require us each year to follow
our graduates and make sure that they're
placed in a salon we even have to show
proof on social media in our
documentation of this
so we have to have
a minimum of 60 percent placed in salons
or spas or barber shops
and
we are always above that we're always
above that and a lot of the times we
can't find find the students that kind
of fall off the planet after they
graduate so it's hard to get get someone
you know make sure they replace but we
do a really good job of connecting with
businesses and as far as the blow dry
bars i do know there's a lady named jody
donlin
who has been to both our career fairs
and um
called me recently she's she's having an
open house and she's opening up one in
bedford one in nashville one in hudson
and they're opening up one in the
seacoast area in dover so the blow-dry
bars are opening up and that was a trend
um and i apologize i forget your name
sir
mr klein
well mr klein
was talking about the trends and that is
a true statement
new hampshire is usually a little bit
behind the rest of the country as far as
hair trends so that's more the reason
why it's coming to us last because
when i was in braintree there was a
blow-dry bar in the in the mall there
and um it did fantastic you know but
this was probably eight nine years ago
and now it's coming to new hampshire
more um
but there's definitely no shortage
representative thank you one more mr
chairman uh so uh and the services that
that a blow dry bar would provide
uh are they currently available at uh
beauty salons
yes yes uh in the salons i ran we did
blow drys but what they're trying to do
now is just specialize in blow drying in
these plates in these establishments
thank you i'd be checking them out soon
all right representative schuett
thank you mr chair
mr lambert these
blow dry bars that are opening do you
know
all right any other questions from the
committee seeing none i have i do have a
question there's a pink card here from
akira collier
okay indicating that you're representing
empire beauty school
um
i understand
okay so
we also have cheyenne over here as well
another student thank you
so at this point um folks just
so that a lot of you understand the
process
for those looking to speak on this bill
moving forward we ask that you bring
testimony that's different than what
we've heard already
rather than just kind of repeating what
we've what we've heard so far so
miss caller if you if you have something
you want to add
and also too for those of you that are
just in have an opinion one way or the
other the blue sheets are available over
on the wall to register your opinion
where you don't necessarily have to
speak if you don't want to but you want
to
reference you know your opinion one way
hello my name is cheyenne bim i'm a
current student at empire beauty school
i am opposed to this bill
i'd like to just thank you all for your
time firstly
i'd like to also add on to what our
the 1500 hours it's more than just
learning about cutting and coloring hair
we learn
the anatomy of the whole human body we
learn
the diseases that could affect the scalp
and the skin and how to safely handle
them
we learn what products are safe to use
we learn
so much more than just
hair
we learn the chemical compounds in here
we learn
how to reshape them safely
we learn how to safely handle these
chemicals
um
sorry i
am a little anxious
i do think this poses a huge safety
hazard against
people who would like to seek these
services i mean there's a science behind
a shampoo believe it or not whenever we
shampoo your hair your hair
we aren't just throwing some shampoo and
conditioner in there and rinsing you out
we're
thinking about the massage movements
analyzing your scalp analyzing your hair
it's much more than just
coming in and
throwing something in your hair and
calling it a day you know
um we're also trained and licensed and
certified in barbicide that's an epa
registered disinfectant
we use it on our brushes we use it on
our scissors our combs all of our
equipment
and that's definitely something i'd be
concerned about for people who are not
licensed
is
where will they receive all these
certifications
wonderful thank you
are there any questions from the
committee
representative grota and then schuett
thank you could you kindly spell your
name
oh yes it is c h e y
e
n n e
representative stewart
thank you i just wanted to thank you for
uh bravely coming up and testifying
thank you so much
all right seeing no further questions
all right miss collier
hi my name is kira collier and i am here
on the behalf of empire beauty school i
currently attend i enrolled in november
2020 and i will be graduating april um
i would just like to say it's not so
much
i do oppose this bill because i will say
in
behalf of the eyelash extensions and
removal um
we do consider that adhesive a chemical
whether you consider that the eyelashes
are separated or blocked off or anything
like by that
it comes down to i would say i question
all of you
if you took two strangers in front of
you right now and you said you wanted to
get eyelash extensions or you wanted
somebody to blow dry your hair or you
wanted anybody touching your body
physically are you going to
lean towards the person that is licensed
and certified to do these services or
are you going to trust somebody that has
no license whatsoever to touch you
i also say with the eyelash extensions
you do go through further certification
other than just your cosmetology license
you have to obtain that or you go
through your aesthetics program
but say somebody has an adverse reaction
to that adhesive
are you more comfortable having somebody
who's certified and qualified to take it
off and remove it and has a license to
rely on for it or are you going to just
have like one of your friends that's not
trained to do it so say you have an
allergic reaction do you want somebody
that has a license that you can hold
accountable
for that or do you want whatsoever who
at the end of the
day you have no accountability from that
person because hey you trusted me to do
it and i don't have a license to say
that i am certified to do it personally
if i were to go to the hospital the er
with an allergic reaction to an adhesive
or
a burn on my scalp that was severe from
somebody that was not licensed i have
nothing to hold that person accountable
for injuring me or causing a reaction
whereas with a license somebody can take
that
to law like a lawsuit and i would be
more comfortable personally having
somebody that i can be like hey you
injured me hey you did this and maybe
they would get you know um
in trouble for it quote unquote
um but i just think at the end of the
day
i'm not i don't personally think it's
going to create more jobs by letting
um and i think it's a personal decision
for each and every student with me we've
it and i think that
at the end of the day we go through all
of this training and as for other
schools and other states requiring less
hours and people thinking
are attesting that the 15 hours 1500
hours is excessive
i started going to school my first
school i started with was not empire
beauty school i started going to
continental
and beauty school in hudson and we had
more than half of the girls that
attended there with us were actually
from massachusetts and they
chose to go to a new hampshire school
because they believed that
the 1500 hours was better than just
getting a thousand hours they felt more
comfortable going to a school where they
were required to have more hours in
training
than their hometowns of massachusetts
if you have any other questions that's
all
thank you for your testimony
hi my name is kelly cross kelly marie is
my formal name but kelly cross i'm miss
kelly to these guys i am an instructor
with empire beauty schools i'm also
licensed in the state of new hampshire
for so long that my license only has
three numbers i've been licensed in new
hampshire for 28 years
and i'm definitely opposed to this bill
i've worked in new hampshire i've moved
to california ohio
and reciprocated there moved to
california and reciprocated there so i
do have some experience elsewhere in the
country i think that the 15 hours 1500
hours that we have in this state
is absolutely necessary and it is the
bare minimum that we have or that we
need to be able to accomplish what we
need to accomplish
and to be able to walk into a salon and
be confident in knowing that we are able
to take care of all of the issues that
could potentially arise
um
sorry i just wrote my i'm like i'm a
little heated right now so i'm going to
try to keep my composure
sorry thank you i put my heart and soul
into it for 28 years
and i
take very great
issue with anything that i feel
threatens that
one of the issues that i wanted to bring
up that no one has brought up so far as
far specifically the blow dry bars
is the tools that we use to blow dry and
flat iron and curl hair
all of those they can reach up to 450
500 degrees they can pose a safety risk
for people it would be very easy to burn
people
if you're not educated on how to use
these tools properly also you know how
to properly disinfect them and perform
maintenance on these tools
is something that we cover
as far as like
people wanting to offer these specialty
services and just have just these
limited
salons that offer niche services
in my opinion this is very similar to a
doctor who only wants to practice
pediatrics or gynecology he still has to
go through and get his original md
license before he can become a
specialist
and yes it may be a different degree but
also we do cover a lot more than just
blow drying your hair
i would challenge anyone in this room
who is not experienced in doing hair to
pick up a blow dryer and a curling iron
and no and do what these guys can do
you're not going to be able to
understand it or to do it you very
easily um you could burn somebody's hair
off you can burn their scalp to where
their hair will never grow back
it's not something that's just like oh
i'm just going to willy nilly pick up a
blow dryer and be able to perform this
as far as it being like a low level
skill set again i would challenge you to
ask any of my students behind me whether
they think that a proper blowout is is a
low level skill set it takes a lot of
knowledge of the hair textures varying
different hair textures everyone in this
room has a different hair texture that
needs to be treated differently
and that if the service is not performed
safely it can cause lasting damage to
your scalp and your hair if you're not
trained on how to do these things
properly it's not as low level as some
people might think that it is
the same thing with applying the
eyelashes and the makeup you know
these are different chemicals that we
work with even just down to a shampoo
knowing which shampoo to use on people
and recognizing allergic reactions is
something that we train our students to
do there's a reason hair school takes
1500 hours
we are like one of my students was
saying you know we do cover anatomy and
physiology we teach the children how to
or the students excuse me how to
recognize
allergic reactions that are happening to
recognize skin conditions
to
safely avoid causing damage to their
clients
as far as
the eyelash adhesives being something
that people can pick up in the drugstore
and do at home and children can do it so
is hair color that doesn't mean it's
safe and that doesn't mean it should be
regulated shouldn't be regulated hair
color you can i can go to cvs right now
and buy it and put it on myself but that
doesn't mean it's a safe thing for me to
do and it doesn't mean that it's not
something that should be regulated
it can still be risky and damp and
dangerous and it can still cause injury
to someone even if something as far as
getting
product in the eyes
i personally have known three people
that have had their eyelashes glued shut
and had to go to the emergency room and
have it fixed for them three that's just
my personal experience i've known three
people that that's happened to
because it wasn't done properly by
someone who is
properly trained to do these things
as far as the business models
you know looking for a less expensive
option to the to the licensure i would
just say that that
if you are going to open a business in
new hampshire the licensure required
ought to be part of your business plan
and it ought to be incorporated into
your business plan when you are
accounting for the cost of opening that
business and if you cannot afford the
cost of properly licensing the
professionals that you work with perhaps
you should open a different business
with less restrictions or perhaps you
should rethink your business model so
sorry i kind of jumped all over the
place i was writing notes as people were
talking
but i'm happy to take any questions that
thank you mr chairman would you be able
to answer the question that i asked mr
lambert with regard to how many
cosmetology licensees we currently have
in new hampshire
i'm sorry i do not know that
representative schmidt i think the only
person that's going to be able to answer
all right thank you and thank you for
miss heidel if you have
something different to offer
than what we've heard already please
please feel free
hello my name is vanessa haydel and i'd
like to thank you guys first and
foremost for allowing me to speak um
i am coming up here today because i do
not agree with the passing of the bill
however
after listening to some very
very well points that have been made by
others in support of the bill
um i feel that
excuse me i apologize um
so i feel that
by
having um
an education in cosmetology specifically
blow drying and washing hair and
everything as other people have made the
point that you've already heard
um it does
you have to have education on that to
make sure there's no contraindications
that occur to the client that you're
taking care of
and also for the cultural and financial
aspect i
heavily agree with that as well i do
feel that the best option would be
to have a certain type of certification
um
that
allows people to get the proper
education for sanitation because that's
very important especially nowadays with
everything going around
um
but however it is it is pricey it is a
pricey um
cost for tuition
um
but i feel that if people want to go
into blow drying or doing eyelash
extensions that of course there should
be a course
for them to take just to make sure that
they're up and current with everything
that is changing because as you know
everything's changing in cosmetology
it's a very fast paced fast-moving um
career
so yes that is my
main points that i well thank you so
much for for coming before us does the
committee have any questions
seeing none thank you i'm gonna call
john brown from the department of
justice
yeah thank you
committee i'm going to be very brief and
i'm going to speak to an issue that
hasn't been
addressed up to this point
my name's john brown i'm an attorney
with the consumer protection and
anti-trust bureau at the attorney
general's office
and um i want to speak specifically
about
the portion of the proposed legislation
that deals with the consumer protection
act
the attorney general's office doesn't
have any position on whether this
legislation should be enacted or not i
um on behalf of the bureau i'm just
raising a couple of of issues that uh
that i'd like the board to consider
um
what i'm specifically
referencing with the consumer protection
language is part 8
of the
proposed statute
which
has the title new section barbering
cosmetology and aesthetics reputation
bottom of page two correct
and um
what this what this portion of of the
proposed legislation would do it would
essentially create a new statute within
the
barbering cosmetology and aesthetics
practice act and just to just to read
the the language here because that's
what we're going to be talking about um
roman numeral 1 it shall be unlawful for
any person to use an unfair deceptive
act or practice in the provision of any
service
authored under this chapter
or deceptive act or practice shall
include the making publishing
dissemination circulation aiding and
abetting or the encouraging of any
making publication or dissemination of
any oral or written statement that is
false disparaging and intended to injure
the reputation of a person licensed
under this chapter
and then roman numeral 2 any violation
of paragraph 1 shall be subject to
enforcement pursuant to rsa 358 a4 which
is part of the consumer protection act
um
the the first uh point that i'd like to
to make is that
um
under that section of the consumer
protection act which is the civil
enforcement
it gives the attorney that part of the
act gives the attorney general's office
the authority to enforce the act
civilly
um
the
i want to just
reference the language in that
particular part of the consumer
roman numeral iii
whenever the attorney general has reason
to believe that trade or commerce
declared unlawful by this chapter has
been is being or is about to be
conducted by any person the attorney
general may bring an action and it
continues the key language there is that
the attorney general has the authority
to enforce violations of this chapter
which means the consumer protection act
so what this
essentially the the new statute is
creating a a new language a new area of
enforcement for the attorney general's
office that is outside of the consumer
so in in in a sense the consumer
protection act is written so that it
essentially can enforce the prohibited
conduct that is listed in the consumer
protection act and it doesn't
necessarily include prohibited acts that
are in other chapters in this case the
practice act for the profession
um so that's that's an issue that i just
asked the board to to consider
the second issue is that the consumer
protection act already has similar
language to what's being proposed
um
rsa 358 a
2 which lists the unlawful acts roman
numeral 8
is disparaging the good services or
business of another by false or
misleading representation of fact
so that is similar but not exactly the
same as the the proposed language uh but
it does create the issue of having sort
of a redundant um statute that
essentially is is prohibiting the same
kind of contact uh conduct
but it also creates the additional
problem of not being identical to the
language of the consumer protect
protection act so essentially we have
um the new legislation which is sort of
more expansive and and
and not an exact mirror of the of what's
in the consumer protection act already
um so that's the second issue i asked
the board
the committee to consider
next um i just want to advise the the
committee
that the
consumer protection act
um provides remedies but there are other
remedies outside the consumer protection
act for the kind of disparaging comments
that that the legislation
is intended to prevent
there are civil actions for slander and
libel that that could
solve the problem
but there is also
within the practice act
the board has disciplinary authority to
discipline licensees for unprofessional
conduct and this kind of
disparagement making false statements
about a competitor that probably fits
the definition of unprofessional conduct
so there are already tools available to
the um the consumer protection act is
really primarily
a tool for protecting consumers from
unscrupulous businesses
not necessarily to protect businesses
from each other
the
consumer protection bureau only learned
of this
legislation recently so we did not have
an opportunity to
calculate what the impact would be if
this legislation passed on our bureau
but
at least in theory if this part of the
statute of this proposed statute were to
pass that could generate additional
complaints
which would require additional expense
and resources for us to address
that's the end of my comments i'd be
happy to take any questions that you
have
thank you representative lucas
thank you um
so
true kind of a two-part question uh the
first is
you know if we were to pass this um
but we removed section 8
do you believe you would be able to
deal with the sort of issues that
i apologize um i think the consumer
protection act as it's as it's worded
um does prohibit um
disparaging the goods or services or
businesses of another by false or
misleading representation of fact and
and i think that is uh broad enough that
it probably would cover
most of the kinds of complaints that i
would anticipate that could come in
under under the statute
um and and like i said there are other
options as well administratively
um
the uh board of barbering cosmetology
and aesthetics does have the
you know the
authority to enforce
um sanctions on licensees for misconduct
and i think this would fit
unprofessional
follow-up
given that i was
why are you concerned you know that
keeping section 8 would cause additional
work and expense if you're already
in a position to deal with
well there's no way for me to know what
whether or not there would be additional
complaints except that
because there's an additional statute it
could be that someone looking at this
statute and feeling that there was a
violation might submit a complaint under
this statute whereas normally their
other option would be
filing it with our office under the
consumer protection act
okay thank you
thank you mr chairman so uh attorney
brown uh
is a reference to 541a
uh
missing here and should be
are you talking about the the
administrative procedures act i am
referring to that yes
um
i don't i don't think so because the
the
the barbering cosmetology and aesthetics
practice act which is
separate from the administrative
procedures act does specifically
prohibit unprofessional conduct and
makes it subject to board discipline um
i i
i think the
i don't know that there's anything
specifically in the administrative
procedures act that would that prohibits
this conduct but the practice act for
that profession i believe does
representative marsh
uh yes thank you mr chairman and thank
you tony brown for coming before us
attorneys sometimes write things that
are hard to understand but i i want you
to help me to understand this section a
here a little bit better on line six it
sounds like to me that this section
uh specifically protects the reputation
of people licensed that means the people
that are currently licensed to do
cosmetology
but it doesn't offer any protection to
people who are not licensed that means
the new people under the spill am i
interpreting that correctly to think
that the cosmetology licensed people
could say disparaging remarks about the
health and safety of all these new
businesses that are being opened up with
impunity under this section but the
other people would not be able to reply
it it appears to me the way that it's
written if i if i understand your
question correctly it appears that the
way it's written
says it shall be unlawful for any person
to use an unfair deceptive act or
practice in the provision of any service
so my assumption is that those are
people that are either
licensed in providing a service or
are engaged in a profession that's not
licensed
but in this case because it is specific
to the practice act
i would assume that what it's referring
to is
uh thank you i just
this is uh continues to confuse me
do we have any other questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you sir
from the representative from the oplc
who can answer
representatives
rakia medley i am the administrator in
the division of enforcement and the
chief of compliance
i'm here to
say that oplc does not take a position
on this bill however
the board of barbarian cosmetology and
aesthetics did take a vote and they do
oppose this bill
and i believe there are a few questions
regarding
numbers so if i could be in of any
assistance for that
i'm here to answer those questions
thank you very much
representative schmidt
thank you mr chairman and and i've asked
several times uh uh
the question how many licensees do we
currently have
among the cosmetologists of new
hampshire
the number of cosmetology uh licensees
we have is just under nine thousand
so eight thousand eight hundred and
ninety three
nine thousand you say just under nine
thousand nine thousand okay and that's
just for cosmetologists
any other questions from the committee
for oplc
seeing none thank you for coming and
all right with no other pink cards i'm
going to close the hearing on house bill
mr lambert and ms bim please bring your
mr lambert i also need the one from
cheyenne
all right this hearing has run over
i'm going to continue with house bill
1560 but i hope we can avoid repeating
information that was provided for house
bill 1171
and
we we will be delaying the afternoon
events
the afternoon festivities because we'll
opening the hearing on house bill 1560
thank you madam chair and honorable
committee members as the prime sponsor i
appreciate the opportunity to introduce
to you today house bill 1560
relative to non-resident licensure by
the board of barbering cosmetology and
aesthetics
for the record i am representative diane
power i represent the towns of brookline
and mason
in hillsborough county district 26
this bill modifies the requirements for
a non-resident licensure by the board of
barbering cosmetology and aesthetics
the issue that this bill addresses
is that under current new hampshire law
out of state barbers cosmetologists and
estheticians who have completed their
education out of state
have obtained the required training
hours
have passed the professional licensing
exam and currently hold a valid license
face significant barriers to be able to
work in new hampshire due to current
laws and derived rules
these licensed professionals have met
the standards and requirements of a
state licensing body
and have the credentials to provide
services to consumers
the obstacle is that licensed beauty
professionals who move to new hampshire
are currently prohibited from working in
their field
unless they successfully navigate
onerous requirements in order for the
state of new hampshire to recognize
their current out-of-state professional
licenses
this is unnecessary and burdensome this
hinders individuals from working in our
state
and this hurts our economy
the solution that this bill provides is
simple
it amends current law to recognize
out-of-state barbering cosmetology and
aesthetics licenses
notably this bill removes the red tape
for beauty professionals who have a
current beauty license from another
state streamlining the process
and it repeals
vague quote substantially equivalent
language in current statute
in conclusion
this bill applies only to licensed
beauty professionals holding a current
valid out-of-state license
this bill requires the board of
barbering cosmetology and aesthetics to
recognize
out-of-state licensing licenses without
further requirements
this bill enables these already licensed
professionals to be able to work in new
hampshire without delay
contributing to our economy
and lastly
this bill benefits workers employers
and consumers
by creating greater access to skilled
labor and professionally licensed
services in the granite state
that concludes my bill introduction
madam chair i am happy to answer any
questions at this time if you allow
thank you are there any questions
all right we would appreciate a copy of
your written testimony
and i don't see any questions that was
this is a much simpler bill thank you
is representative petrie still here
he left all right thank you we won't
thank you madam chairman members of the
committee
for the record i am representative
jennifer rhodes i represent win cheshire
district 15 winchester richmond marble
swansea and troy
as representative power said um
this bill is i guess a little bit
opposite of of the one we just heard we
are talking about people that do have a
license from another state that wish to
continue
working in the profession that they've
already been licensed in
when you move to the state of new
hampshire
which is mentioned there are several
obstacles that you have to overcome some
of them
are are not the fault of the person that
holds the licensee at all as an example
if you attend a cosmetology school that
closes
you don't have the ability to
to get the transcripts from that school
that show that you went there and that
is one of the requirements
that the state of new hampshire
currently has that you show in order to
have reciprocity
another obstacle is if you have a high
school that closes a lot of schools are
are forming regional school districts
therefore a lot of high schools are
closing if you're a person that just
doesn't know where your high school
diploma is
you may not have the ability to get a
copy of your high school transcripts or
your diploma to show that you have that
if you currently hold
an actual current license from another
state
your skills do not change when you move
to the state of new hampshire you are
not doing anything different
as was mentioned you still already have
passed the test you've already proven
yourself if you have a license and you
are asked
if you have a family member that is
being transferred and you come to the
state of new hampshire and you don't
have the required hours that new
hampshire takes you have to show proof
that you worked in a salon for x amount
of hours
or show that you have these skills
that again that's that's an unnecessary
obstacle when you graduate from school
you get your current license and you go
work they don't say wait
you can't start working until you're an
apprentice for so many hours
so i strongly recommend
that the committee ought to pass this
bill
as presented and i'll be happy to answer
any questions
thank you are there questions
representative horrigan
thank you very much madam chairman thank
you mr i'm just substituting on this
committee today but i did hear your
testimony in the previous bill
representative rhodes and um
[Music]
first question is um
are there states where the requirements
are much less than they are here in new
hampshire
or ours
make because i know we have a i heard
several times
that there's a 1500 hour requirement
rather than a thousand but it's the
cosmetology curriculum otherwise is it
significantly tougher or is it about the
same as other states
like
the the information that you're
requesting is certainly available online
i did have
a list at one time of all the states and
what they required i would say that new
hampshire is probably somewhere in the
middle of those some certainly require a
lot more some certainly acquire a lot
less the fact of the matter is the skill
is still the same regardless of the
state line representative
follow up
one follow-up
yeah so
i know
colleges and universities when they shut
down are required to transfer their uh
their records to another institution as
part of the shutdown process so that you
know somebody can get their transcript
is that to your knowledge uh
not the same with professional schools
such as beauty schools
i don't own a beauty school
representative i don't know the answer
to your question okay
all right thanks are there any other
questions for representative rhodes
seeing nand thank you very much thank
you madam chair representative petrie
thank you madam chair uh thank you for
uh
let me testify here in front of the the
colleagues
51 states have required 51 states 50
states in d.c have the requirements
the ones
in my research i found that
new york was a thousand hours versus our
1500. i haven't seen any other or more
than 1500.
um
getting back to my wife
she went to school in boston
she knew she was going to need 1500
hours in new hampshire so she
went that route she worked a couple
years in
massachusetts
when she transferred to new hampshire
which is her home
she uh
she was required to take the practical
you can go all through the
hoops to get uh
you know to get certified as a as a
hairdresser or a beautician
cosmetologist whatever you want to call
her and
you know that's that's quite a that's
quite a load
to have to go through that
again
when you should be able to just transfer
when you get a driver's license in
another state you just come to the state
and if you've had one before
there you go just like and another thing
i don't know one thing i noticed
come to mind i see these nurses come in
and do their
nursing here when uh during this
pandemic here in manufact recently
and i'm sure that they're
i don't know if it was waived or
whatever but that's
that's pretty serious stuff
thank you representative petry
i don't see any questions so thank you
for your testimony
uh thank you chairman and members i'll
be much shorter this time uh drew klein
from the desire bartlett center
um
so this bill is it would strip the
equivalency language
under these licenses and we think this
language is subjective
and not necessary new hampshire's in a
pretty significant labor shortage right
now
what we need are people to move here
and
this bill would do that in a way that
does not compreh compromise health and
safety in any way and just to give you
some other examples um
really quickly new hampshire for barbers
new hampshire requires 800 hours of
training in an approved school or 1600
hours under a licensed barber that's
actually very low compared to most other
states for barber licenses we do very
well
um
from vermont maine and mass require a
thousand hours connecticut rhode island
core 1500
there are only a few states that have
lower requirements
oregon for example requires 746 hours of
training
with the subjective language in there
making it substantial equivalent
it's not going to compromise the health
or safety you know in barbering um for
cosmetology the folks behind me will
have more robust numbers but we're not
that far off so it's not like we're
lowering standards with this bill what
we're doing is just making it easier for
people to immediately get into new
hampshire without additional hurdles
that's all thank you mr klein are there
questions
representative scitec
mr klein uh you said you're not lowering
standards but if if the requirements are
1500 here and a thousand
elsewhere haven't you exactly done that
lowered the standards
we don't think
so in the sense that
the qualifications that you're doing
with these hours um
are
somewhat arbitrary
there are new hampshire used to have a
two thousand hour license requirement
for cosmetologists now we're down to
fifteen hundred mass has a thousand lots
of other states
have different numbers and we haven't
seen any data
that actually
shows a significant increase in public
health or safety
when you increase these hours a little
bit so we don't think there's any danger
to the public because you might have
somebody come in from a state that has a
few
you know 100 hours less in training we
just haven't seen no relationship there
between the number of hours and the
other questions
seeing none thank you very much
good what i believe is now afternoon
members of the executive departments and
administrative committee thank you for
the opportunity to testify in support of
house bill 1560 which would allow the
new hampshire board of barbering
cosmetology and aesthetics to recognize
more quickly out of state beauty
industry professional licenses
all 50 states require cosmetologists
barbers and estheticians to be licensed
every state's beauty school curriculum
beauty practitioner skills and
techniques and beauty services are
nearly identical despite those
similarities it is difficult to have an
out-of-state beauty license recognized
to be able to be recognized in new
hampshire
that's because new hampshire requires
out-of-state beauty license requirements
to be substantially equivalent or higher
than those of new hampshire's license
the arbitrary recognition requirement
restricts the mobility of licensees
which is a problem for beauty
professionals and employers throughout
the state
i encourage this committee to support
house bill 1560 because reducing
licensing barriers creates more
opportunities for the citizens of new
hampshire
first licensing mobility is exceedingly
important employers across the country
are experiencing labor shortages making
it easier for licensed beauty
professionals to work by reducing
barriers will allow employers to have a
wider pool of potential applicants
second the substantially equivalent or
higher than requirement is vague
it creates a chilling effect for
for perfect for potential beauty
professionals who may have an interest
in working in new hampshire
qualified beauty professionals may
choose to not bring their skills to new
hampshire for fear of having to undergo
additional costly and time-consuming
training
third this bill helps to empower women
the largest group of beneficiaries of
this bill are beauty professionals who
have a spouse with a job that that
requires frequent interstate travel
most beauty service professionals are
women and beauty service skills are
easily transferable from state to state
making this industry an attractive
choice for women who want to continue to
support their families while also
advancing their careers
however the time that it takes to have
this quality determination of a beauty
license for these professionals means
that these women are out of work because
of needless bureaucracy which leaves
their career their careers to stagnate
this bill helps to get these women into
work sooner to support their families
and to continue to advance their careers
house bill 1560 makes small changes to
the law that will have large impacts on
beauty professionals who may want to
bring their skills knowledge and
experience to benefit the new
new hampshire's beauty industry
in conclusion i would encourage this
committee to support house bill 1560 so
that skilled beauty professionals can
bring their talents and skills here
these individuals hold a current valid
license and have and have been through
beauty school and they are ready and
willing to work in the state thank you
for the opportunity to testify and i'm
happy to answer any questions that you
thank you
representative goalie
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking the question
we heard an earlier testimony that
there are
individuals coming to new hampshire from
massachusetts for a 1500 hour class when
it's only a thousand hours in
massachusetts
how would you state that that's over
burdensome if they're coming here for
the extra hours knowing that they're
getting a better education and better
qualified to do what they're doing
well so anecdotally
she shared that there are individuals
who are coming from massachusetts to new
hampshire
but we also can say that there are many
individuals in massachusetts who are
going who are undergoing the thousand
hours of training so it's really a
personal choice and and if someone feels
the need to spend that extra time and
would like to spend that extra time to
get that additional training because not
all beauty service professionals are the
same right some people
do train outside of a traditional
classroom and so they need to
they want to train at it at a more
advanced level some people need to
continue to
work on the foundational skills and so
maybe that's why those individuals are
coming into new hampshire to get that
extra 500 hours of training
so i can't speak to exactly why every
you know why every single individual
chooses to come to new hampshire but it
certainly is a is a personal choice um
but we do know that states across the
country are lowering their hours
requirements and beauty professionals
are taking note and are excited about
those opportunities because they choose
and they don't want to spend
a substantial amount of money on
traditional cosmetology school training
and just to follow up on
as we talk about massachusetts well it's
a thousand hours is it not true that
they also have to do some hours after
that in the field and do you know how
many hours it is for training afterwards
yes so statutorily in massachusetts
there's only a thousand hour training
requirement but what you'll find across
the country and with many beauty
professionals is that they want to do
additional training to learn their
specialty skill and so even though they
graduate with this cosmetology degree
and they have their license because
that's what's required they want to
specialize in what they're doing so they
go and they get you know the makeup
certification they go and get the
eyelash certification and we're we're
totally for that we want everyone to be
trained we want you to feel very
comfortable in your educational skills
um in
your education and the skills that you
provide it's just what we what we know
is that the state mandated license
requirement means very little to
consumers and it also is a huge barrier
um for professionals who want to get to
work quickly
other questions from the committee
representative
did you state in your testimony that
a majority of the women
who are who could benefit from this
allies license
have husbands who do interstate travel
yes that would be a large group of of
individuals who would be able to benefit
from this from the spill so um if if
you're thinking of someone um who has um
who's a spouse of someone in the
military um they would be more able or
more quickly able to have their their
license recognized and be able to get to
work more quickly um here in new
hampshire if the bill were to be enacted
it seems rather a tiny portion of the
when you say a large portion it doesn't
that doesn't ring true to me do you have
data on the road sorry she's answered
your question
uh yes
that's
please don't argue with her i'm not i'm
are there any other questions
i have uh one
procedural question
no
well um
i'm legislative counsel for the
institute for justice and i'm paid
through them but they're
i'm not paid by any particular
organization in new hampshire
okay we will look into whether that
counts as a lobbyist but uh thank you
for your testimony oh i'm a registered
lobbyist and you are original i am
rapping yes i am a registered lobbyist
in the state
okay we just missed your orange badge
oh
today is my first uh time testifying
here in new hampshire so i i may have
skipped okay yes
we're used to seeing lobbyists having
orange badge so we can tell them apart
my apologies we know that they're not
not the prey they're among the hunters i
i will i'll
get that badge
thank you very much i appreciate that
thank you okay are there any other
questions
okay seeing none is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on house bill 1560
all right not seeing any i'm going to
close the
hearing and i'm going to
move the hearing on how
the one o'clock hearing from house bill
which is scheduled for one o'clock
to 1 25
because the sponsor just sent a note
saying
we don't need this bill please kill it
so i think we can do that in less than
half an hour
oh yeah
okay so we will resume at 125 on house
bill 1545
these bills will be going to
subcommittee
good afternoon welcome back to edna
i'm opening the public hearing on house
bill 1545
and i call on representative goalie to
so
thank you madam chair
uh
and for the record i will fill out a
pink card uh when i'm done
uh for the record representative jeff
goalie representing hillsborough 8
manchester ward 1
and here today to introduce house bill
relative to a state directory for film
production
i believe the sponsor
contacted the chair and also emailed
in regards to some correspondence they
have had with the
travel and tourism industry and their
work on putting together some of the
issues that were going to be addressed
in this piece of legislation
such as film locations and how
individuals could reach out to
production crews or those that do
work around the film industry
so
with that being said and that being done
the sponsor has reached out and asked
that we
i tl this piece of legislation
so with that being said
unless you have any
untechnical questions
well i would after that clear
explanation i can't imagine there are
any tech any questions
so thank you representative goalie
as a matter of courtesy and respect
representative pearson we will not ask
him any irrelevant questions i will say
that i
saw the the email from representative
wilhelm and i also saw the the response
from
lori hornoy who was the director of
travel and tourism and she pointed out
where all the data is
and so
the sponsors are happy
the
tdt is already doing what they want and
so we don't need a bill to to tell them
otherwise
oh sorry
my mistake closing the hearing on house
bill 1545
opening the hearing on house bill 1287
thank you madam chair thank you
members of
the committee
i brought
before you today hb
relative to
proclaiming uh sleep awareness month
um
as you
are aware uh
i have for a number of years been
trying to
see how to address or have addressed
daylight savings times issues
and the ramifications of those issues
including the loss of sleep and the
danger and
the health
effects
of those loss of sleep
a lot of the opposition to that
legislation
is that there
should be a federal solution
and so
what i'm proposing
to you today
is not only should we bring awareness
about the dangers of the lack of sleep
because
they are
and
also take the opportunity to
request that our
federal representatives address this
issue
post haste
and
so i tried to do
two birds kind of with one stone as long
as we're having days and um
months and weeks that we recognize and
try and bring attention to issues i
think that um
sleep
of it on health and safety
is
hard to understate
based on the evidence that we have thus
far
and i'm happy to um
uh point you to
um the sleep national sleep associate
foundation
other such places that house research on
that if if the there is questions about
the effects of
how how how important the the
sleep can affect everything from
diabetes to obesity to
potentially even alzheimer's and cancer
and so this is um
i've i believe a very important thing
that we need brought awareness to
and
i understand from conversations with
committee members that they are not in
super big favor of having days and weeks
and proclamations and
all of that um but as long as we're
doing it
until we repeal all of that i think that
um
this topic is one that deserves the
committee's attention and so with that
i'm happy to answer any questions
thank you representative representative
seitek has a question
did i hear you say that it's
hard to understate the importance of
this
of sleep yeah
yes it sounded like you said that right
it's thank you representative scitec for
that useful comment representative marsh
thank you madam chairman thank you
representative for taking my question uh
does the national sleep foundation have
a position on uh the adoption of
atlantic standard time or permanent
daily savings time
or not
yes
so so they actually are the ones
they launched back in 1998
a sleep awareness program and
they do
uh suggest the adoption of us
a time which does not
fluctuate throughout the year so that we
can have the um thank you for that yeah
thank you
other questions representative schuett
and then
thank you madam chair
representative um it seems that the
major thrust
of what you're doing here is to
send a message
to the u.s
congress and senate
i'm reading that language that you want
the governor to address the issue to
them why wouldn't you just
introduce a resolution which would send
a message from our whole legislature
to the delegation
which seems to me a more proper way than
putting something in statute
thank you for the question
um as i stated i think that bringing
awareness to this issue is a is an
important one in general and also
um
the
a proclamation
or house resolution getting sent to them
would only
um be sent once and if this was in
statute as as is suggested in law it
would be
it would be reiterated every s
with every new um person getting elected
they would be
um as long as we're
we're having this delatorious
effect on our on our citizens and on our
nation that each one of those new
representatives as they get elected
should be aware that this is an issue
that new hampshire wants
addressed by them i think
representative phillip
thank you madam chair um my question is
closely related to that
um i my concern was
the governor is supposed you're telling
the governor something he needs to do
every year
and i just what if the governor doesn't
thank you for the question
we
have multiple
requirements for
declarations of different days and
different like the government governor
just did a declaration of black history
month right all of those things
can be um
in statute also
whether or not he um that one specific
one is in statute they are
are um
it's just another way of having the
issue brought to the attention of people
under especially in march when the
daylight savings time is affecting them
it should be you know friend of mine
thank you
thank you are there other questions
representative pierce
one of the things that uh when we see
these
the various types of legislation that's
brought forward
along these lines um
you know
they they all have a tendency to state
something similar in the sense of
observe this month in an appropriate
manner
early on in the state's history they
would have the phrase celebratory
gunfire i mean there was there was all
kinds of stuff that used to come in here
what but in all seriousness though you
know observ
observe the month in an appropriate
manner to raise awareness what do you
from the governor's perspective i think
just a proclamation
of the of
that that this is
um
that the loss of sleep during the
daylight savings time
era is something that
you know
affects public safety as far as
increased car crashes increased heart
work related in
accidents
all of those things
um you know
could be
done
or mentioned inside of such a
proclamation and then
people reading that would be
able to research that information
further and get more informed
can i have a follow-up
thank you
madam chair
sleep issues connected with
daylight savings time and not the
overall
concept of
appropriate levels of sleep
the
reason that
march is chosen is because of the
specific of the loss of sleep that
happens in that month
right
um
that does not mean that it is not
important the rest of the year it's just
brought to a point because the
as as a
a country we are
having a
negative effect on our citizens at that
point and so
it it offers us the opportunity while
we're not actually fixing the problem
that we can suggest hey you might be
mindful of you're going to lose sleep if
you don't um
adjust your habits
that over this weekend maybe go to sleep
an hour earlier so that
the
you won't have these negative effects
of
the uh
the change what of the time while you're
sleeping and therefore um would
help to decrease your amount of
risk from damage uh from
the the time switching and so i think
it's a
it's a pinpoint in time that that we
should bring awareness to it but it's a
very very big issue all the days of the
year
thank you representative chute you have
a follow-up
sort of a new topic
i've been around this whole planet quite
a while
and i can remember
the actual date of changing the times
has changed
changed dates changed months
what happens if we decide that we're not
going to do this until april and we have
thank you for the question
if we were to amend the
the statute that says the second week in
march then we would also be able to
amend this bill but or this this statute
technically but um
generally those changes actually
are to
the other time frame of trying to get it
earlier
um
they're trying to expand
it into
more into summer
is is my understanding of those changes
and so
i'm not sure that that
that
would come up and hopefully it wouldn't
come up they would just fix the time and
thank you that we all hope that this
will this issue will be uh conquered at
some point
any uh other questions
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking the question i
know the speaker's in the way for me
seeing you
um
i know this
evolves around daylight savings time and
the issue with that
but is it not true that tens of
thousands of
citizens travel on a daily basis outside
of their time zone whether it be one
time zone or two or three time zones
away being deprived of sleep and their
clock being put off on a regular basis
thank you for that question
and yes the
the negative impacts are
often referred to as jet lag
and that
um
is
the grogginess that someone feels when
they
are trying to reset their clock
their internal clock based on this new
um you know
new position on the earth in relation to
the sun
that is
but
if you're not getting enough sleep there
in addition to the jet lag you may have
other health consequences also so
um
there's an opportunity to train to
encourage people that are traveling into
different time zones to
to sleep more
so that they
can lessen those
negative effects absolutely thank you
follow-up so wouldn't you agree that
those traveling
routinely are more at risk than a
thank you for the question as i stated
before
sleep is an issue all of the days
if people don't have
proper sleep schedule
whether that whether they travel or not
it will negatively impact them
and shorten their lifespan and and
also make them much more prone to
disease and have a weaker immune system
and all all the different things and so
yes i think that
people that travel a lot and have a hard
time getting in a
a rhythm of
proper sleep
will
be suffering
these the the negative effects of lack
of sleep and and in fact
um i think uh
there's only
in
in the research there's
suggested as little as three percent of
of um teenagers are getting the
recommended number of hours of sleep and
it's not
um
that much better for for adults so um we
all are harming ourselves and it's
having um a significant impact on our
longevity our health our safety and so
bringing awareness to this it will help
us
have the opportunity to
change our habits and maybe even if
you're traveling then you would be able
to
maybe
be more mindful of when you should sleep
so that you can get the proper amount of
hours of sleep so that your body can
help repair itself
as it is doing when you sleep thank you
thank you i believe this is drifting a
bit representative
fellows you have a question about the
bill
thank you
so so my question is you know
well while you probably remember that i
don't agree with the daylight savings
time thing i certainly do agree that
people should get a lot of sleep or the
right amount and it's a medical issue
because not having enough sleep
in all the situations you've mentioned
plus others can cause problems
but in terms of having a proclamation
are we going to have proclamations for
every kind of
behavior that carries a um you know a
medical
benefit
to it i mean eat your vegetables and i
mean we could go on and on so i'm
wondering if how appropriate you feel
this is as a proclamation related to
health
thank you for the the question um i
do remember that you um opposed the
proposed changes from me about daylight
savings time and suggested that it
should be a federal issue so i would
hope that you would be supportive of
asking the federal people to address it
so that i would stop coming back to your
committee however
um
i would all appreciate that
representative
thank you
however um as i was as i was stating
before this the um
that the sleep is so fundamental and
it's so it has such an impact it's even
more important than diet and exercise
because they don't they don't have the
effects that you they that you're
seeking if you don't have enough
sleep to
um for your body to
um properly deal with the
exercise and diet that you're trying to
to
maintain um
so
as far as
um
you know what the government should and
should not be doing as far as as
recommending stuff you know they're
the the
government recommended the the chart the
food chart the pyramid which is now
found to be completely bogus and
and causing a lot of disease and and
uh diabetes because we're eating too
many carbs
stuff like that so i i would be
concerned about the government
suggesting a bunch of things but it
i don't think that this is suggesting it
it's just saying you should be educated
on this because it's
negative affecting your health and so
it's not prescribing that this is the
solution like the
food pyramid chart it's saying hey this
is an issue you need to look at look at
this and and learn
educate yourself thank you thank you are
there any
other questions relevant to the bill
okay thank you
seeing none
is there anyone else who wishes to
seeing none i'm going to close the
and does someone wish to make a motion
on house bill 1545
yes we're going into executive session
for just for this one thank you madam
chair i will give representative scitec
a moment to catch up and then i will
make a motion
and i'll be happy to second whatever
oh you're you're taking a chance there
i have full faith and confidence in
representative goalie's next
i move
inexpedient to legislate on house bill
1545.
i'll second that is there a second
representative marsh okay he got there
first
uh do you wish to speak to your motion
thank you madam chair i
believe
during the introduction i
gave a good reason why the sponsors were
looking for an inexpedient to legislate
that the bureau of travel and tourism is
currently
collecting information uh going forward
on what they were looking for and
as of right now they're happy with
what's going on and
asked at this bill the sponsor asked
that this be and expedient the legislate
thank you representative marsh yeah i
would just say that the specific piece
of information is the division of travel
and tourism created a new hampshire film
database which is exactly what the
sponsors asked for that makes the bill
unnecessary
okay thank you any further discussion
before we go any further i'd like to
introduce representative marlow
she's she's filling in for
representative
fontenot and represent horrigan is with
okay the motion is inexpedient to
legislate on house bill 1545 and when
representative rhodes
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson
yes
representative yakubovic yes
representative bailey
yes
representative
santo nestaso
yes
representative goalie
representative schuett yes
representative horrigan
yes
representative schmidt
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative camarlo
yes
representative grota
representative o'brien yes and the chair
yes
um we're too short 17-0
itil
17-17-0
is there any objection to consent
okay
thank you representative rhodes we'll
we'll put you down as the person to
speak on this if it's challenged
madam chair
yes representative stuart yes if if
there's time i think we can dispose of
one other bill
house bill
relative to the governing boards of
recreational therapists
and relative to the governing board of
respiratory care practitioners
and i would move on to pass okay i think
i think the time is just a little short
for that
we've also got two people missing and i
told at least representative allegro
that we wouldn't execute anything while
he wasn't here
while we're on just what quickly while
we're on the topic of 1446 is there an
amendment that's involved with this bill
or is this a straight up not to my
knowledge
we only heard
a few people testify no one was against
it
there's been no signatures online
opposed to it i just have a note in
reference to transitionary language
well why don't you look at your notes
and see if an amendment is needed well
because i don't really want to bring
perhaps after uh one of the other bills
this afternoon they're pretty close
what um
mr representative pearson
do we have a motion perhaps on house
bill 1444. you know
you're absolutely right i do oh yeah
so uh the subcommittee this we can
handle this in the time frame the
subcommittee met this morning on house
bill 1444 which is an early bill
um
we discussed a number of topics that
that range from uh licensing versus just
simply registration
we found that there were some some
language within the bill that
needed a better definition
as far as
and we also found
looking through here that
they this is another bill that wants to
define what
a inspector is going to be paid and not
go through jccc so
it was it was discussed within the
committee that this would would probably
need to go to interim study and that's
the motion i'm making
okay
so your motion is interim study on house
bill 1444. is there a second
second i've taken that sorry
all right
and madame chair i brought this up
because um representative allegro is on
our subcommittee and was part of that
decision process he did in fact
vote for the interim study yes he did
okay thank you yes that's correct
all right is there any further
discussion
representative marsh yes one other issue
that you didn't mention was the issue of
inspections these are basically health
care facilities
and oplc would have to recreate the
ability of hhs to inspect health care
facilities
i did speak to hhs and
floated the idea of would they be
willing to contract with oplc to perform
those inspections for them and they
really don't want to do that so that's
another can of worms that needs to be
addressed and would take considerable
time yes ma'am sure we um there were
representatives from oplc and hhs
present in the subcommittee and we
absolutely address the jurisdictional
boundary problem
between the two of them is something
that needed further
further investigation
i see i i think you just didn't mention
that in your comments it's going to be a
very busy subcommittee i've got to say
our interim study committee
so i hope we will uh
oh no i'm sorry he was looking for
someone to give them oh okay
any other comments
all right in that case the motion is
interim study on house bill 14
representative rhodes yes
clark folks yes representative pearson
yes
representative jacob
representative
yes representative
bailey yes
representative santo nestaso
yes
representative goalie
representative shewit
representative yes
uh yes
representative schmidt
yes
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative gramarlo yes
representative grota
yes
representative o'brien
yes and the chair
yes
17-0
okay the motion passes 17-0 is there any
objection to consent
seeing none we'll put it on consent and
representative pearson i trust you've
written your uh committee report
you put your trust in the wrong place
all right then
thank you we're leaving executive
session
oh
and representative pearson i'm not sure
a full month of celebratory gunfire
could result in a lot of different um
you know
yeah i don't i don't i don't want to be
the drug prescription and i'm weakening
um
it being
1 30 excuse me two o'clock
i'm opening the hearing on house bill
hb 1443 would proclaim the first monday
in march as covet 19 victims and
survivors memorial day
since the start of the pandemic in 2020
there have been over nine hundred
thousand deaths in the united states
and
twenty two hundred and sixty deaths in
the state of new hampshire that have
been attributed to the coronavirus
nationally it's been estimated that over
two hundred thousand children have lost
at least one parent
here in new hampshire our death toll
seems small by comparison
to the staggering national numbers but
by springtime our small states covet 19
death toll will likely equal or surpass
the number of deaths that occurred
in our state and across the country the
elderly and the medically vulnerable
have suffered greatly
although people age 70 and over have
suffered just seven percent of new
hampshire's total the covet 19
infections
this age group has comprised 45 percent
of hospitalizations
and 77 percent of new hampshire's total
coronavirus deaths
while younger people have generally been
spared from the most serious symptoms it
shouldn't be forgotten that our state's
youngest victim
was only nine years old
we also shouldn't forget the sacrifice
of the 19 new hampshire health care
workers claimed by covet 19 since march
covet 19 victims and survivors memorial
day can be one of the days we remember
not only the fathers the mothers the
sons the daughters
and the uh and the grandparents that
we've lost but also the many harsh
lessons that covet 19 has taught us
lessons about the necessity for
preparation the importance of prevention
the essential role of scientists and
public health professionals in the need
for excellence transparency and honesty
in communication
while the pandemic has been a challenge
that has brought out the worst in a few
it has brought out the best in many many
in new hampshire we have 28 special days
weeks and months that we celebrate
we honor teachers with teacher
appreciation week
we honor our past with new hampshire
history week
we set aside days on the calendar to
honor the victims of 9 11
gold star and blue star mothers we even
have a day to honor
the storybook character pollyanna of
littleton
hb 1443 is a way to create a present and
future space for mourning remembrance
and ongoing discussion
it's also a way to let the health care
heroes in our hospitals know that we are
grateful
to thank nursing home staff who despite
low pay and a shortage of ppe
stayed on the job protecting our most
vulnerable residents
to acknowledge the essential workers who
kept our economy going through the
darkest days
and to remember the first responders
public health care workers and citizen
volunteers who did the work of getting
the vaccine to people when they needed
it
passing this bill will send a message
that new hampshire and new hampshire's
leaders will not forget the people who
were lost
the people who suffered
and the people who at great risk to
themselves found ways to help others
and to keep helping
and many of those people are still
helping today
so i ask you to uh to please uh give
this bill
thank you representative muse are there
questions from the committee
representative shua
thank you madam chair um
i'm not sure if this is a question for
the sponsor or for the chair
the bill calls for
the governor to order the flag of the
united states to have staff am i correct
that only the president can do that i
think the governor only controls the
state and state flag
excellent question does anyone know the
answer
representative o'brien
i assume that the governor does have the
authority to lower the flag but in
further reference there is a flag code
that is referenced through uh defense
that you'll be able to research that and
valid validate your inquiry
thank you for saying muse did you
research that before you uh said you
wrote the bill
i'm sorry did you research
that question
when you were looking into this uh what
i what i did do is i looked at some of
the other statutes or some of the other
days and basically mirrored that
language
so if there's a issue with this bill
there's an issue with the language and
some of the other things that we've
already passed
thank you that's
any other questions representative phil
thank you madam chair um i just can you
tell me why you selected this particular
date the first monday in
march i'm just wondering if it aligned
with
a federal
celebration or not celebration
recognition
i think it syncs with the day i think
that most of us realize that this was
going to be a serious problem
um uh
we i think we're meeting after that i
think we met during the first week in
march and we had that 20-hour session
uh because we knew that there wasn't
going to there may not be another one
for a long time based on the way that
the the illness was going
so march of 2020 is generally the time
frame i think that has been accepted for
the start of the covet 19 pandemic in
the united states
and that's the reason for selecting
thank you other questions
seeing none thank you representative
muse thank you very much i call
good afternoon thank you madam chair and
um i beg your indulgence i am for the
very first time uploading my testimony
into the file
that you will apparently share so
hopefully you'll be able to see this um
and so i didn't make copies save a tree
so thank you very much for your time
today
we are mourning in fact every day
we are mourning new hampshire has lost 2
260 citizens
since march 3rd of 2020.
it's been less than two years since this
global pandemic has claimed 904
100 900 thousand
one hundred and forty four american
lives
we've experienced national
statewide community and familial traumas
due to the devastation of covet 19.
in our collective efforts to save lives
we have foregone some of the ways we
traditionally mourn our dead
funerals
celebrations of life
wakes sitting shiva being together to
honor those who have passed
have all been transformed by our
collective efforts to stop the spread of
this virus
a day of memorial is a formal and annual
acknowledgement of the reality of that
trauma
in 2015 the funeral and memorial
information council commissioned a
harris poll of american adults over the
age of 20
and found that 82 percent of those
surveyed
said that a service was helpful in
paying tribute or to commemorating the
life of a friend or a family member and
77 72 percent of those surveyed believed
that services of commemoration were an
important part of that healing process
we honor those who have been taken in
tragedy
with memorials
it helps us heal
it helps us collectively grieve
and collectively remember
respectfully i ask that you find house
bill 1443 ought to pass thank you
thank you representative all chiller are
seeing none thank you thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
okay seeing none
thank you that i'm going to close the
public hearing on
1443.
i'm sure could we ask the dis sponsor
and and co-sponsor who spoke uh to
provide their
testimony
representative all chiller has she's
loaded she says she's loaded it up to
the
file
representative muse appears to have
copies
foreign
all right
welcome back
uh it being 2 30 i'm going to open the
hearing on house bill 1173 and i call
uh thank you madam chair for the record
i'm representative jess edwards
representing
auburn chester and sandown
i want to start out by referring to
sandown
pretty quickly or excuse me chester
representative ford is the primary
sponsor of this bill
i'm not sure where he is right now but
he introduced on a warrant article last
year
the recognition of indigenous people's
day
to
coincide with the u.n
indigenous people's indigenous day on
august 9th and
i was overwhelmingly approved in the
town of chester
you may recall it from last year that
the bill has introduced
proposed putting into just indigenous
people's day
on the same day as columbus day
and
i submitted an amendment last year to
just say
let's go ahead and move indigenous
people's day over to
the u.n day and
this committee i think it was this
committee
approved that overwhelmingly
i i think it is
because
we've had this
fight
for so long
about whether or not
columbus deserves to be part of our
history and if we could get rid of
columbus
by
overwriting
that history
with indigenous people's day this was a
way to kill two birds with one stone i
believe
and what i think would be a healthier
thing for us to do
is to give up on
the intersectional wars
and just recognize that
american indigenous peoples and in new
hampshire that would include the abunaki
that
if we are to respect them as we are to
respect each other
that we would go ahead and designate a
date of recognition for them
and uh have it coincide with the
the un day
now in the u.n um
that day recognizes for
460 million people around the world
that's a whole lot of people
and so i think
this is a way
in a healthier way
to accomplish a couple things with one
bill
we can finally end four or five years of
fighting over whether or not we're going
to have an indigenous people's day
because we can just acknowledge it and
do it
and while doing that we could recognize
the united nations effort there are
there aren't very many times where i
support the united nations in general
because i think they're poorly led and
poorly organized but but this is one
thing i think we could
accept
from
that global entity
and
i believe that's everything i i think i
should say at this point i wasn't
prepared to introduce the bill but i'm
happy to do so if there are any
questions i'm i'm also happy to take
them
thank you representative edwards
representative schmidt has a question
thank you madam chair
well welcome
mr
vice chair um
so
where are the indigenous people on this
bill because as you know they
uh they were not
uh totally unanimous in their
ass in their attitude
uh
about this the last time we tried it uh
and i don't see any of them here and i
haven't heard from any of them so i
don't want to assume anything maybe you
have heard something
this is what i think i know
representative schmidt um thank you for
the question i what i what i think is
that the representative who may be
speaking after me
has maintained as i understand it close
contact with the abunaki and that
based on the testimony we heard last
year
i think that their official position
would be that they would still want to
keep it on columbus day
and um
and i i'm just saying
i love you
let's let's figure out how to agree to
agree
and let's go ahead and give you your day
but let's make it with the u.n
and not continue to fight against what
has become
a celebration of italian immigration to
the united states so so that's a very
i think you're probably right but but we
ought to ask them
any other questions
thank you representative edwards thank
thank you very much madam chair thank
you much for the committee it's actually
somewhat unusual for someone who's
sitting around the committee table to
fill out the pink card and speak against
because
normally
we're supposed to save the negative
comments for the executive session but i
don't even i'm just a substitute so i'm
just here for the day so i probably
won't be here when it's exact whenever
and um
and um so
and i
i seem to be the only uh person who's
come up to testify against the bill but
i have been whether or not it's close
contact like for example i was just
checking a facebook change i did
encourage people to upload their
opposition to the website um i haven't
checked to see how many did but um
and i've uh
supported sponsored several bills
related indigenous people's day
including including one just uh
last year which was tabled as
representative edwards correctly noted
and
this day
those are the first monday in october
which is the same day as the columbus
day holiday is um it's already being
observed as indigenous people's day by
the native community and its allies
including myself officially celebrated
you know
in many communities across new hampshire
including my own hometown of durham and
our local school district the oyster
river school district who actually one
of the first in the state to uh
observe uh indigenous people's day in
october and this october celebration is
very much specifically a celebration of
the first nations of
what we now know is the united states of
america
and i guess it is also specifically
repudiation christopher columbus and you
know well he's a historical figure about
uh
who symbolizes lots of things lots of
people we actually don't know very much
about him but um
and uh so august 9th as representative
edwards correctly noted the united
nations international day of the world's
indigenous peoples it's worthwhile but
somewhat obscure observance
it's not a holiday anywhere i don't
think it's widely celebrated anywhere
it's really only one step up of
significance from national book lovers
day
or national rice pudding day which are
which are also celebrated on august 9th
and actually like many other people i
love books and i enjoy eating rice
pudding but
those celebrations don't deserve to be a
subject of a new hampshire bill such as
hb 1173 and in my opinion the same goes
for the u.n international day of the
world's indigenous peoples some
um you know it's yeah it's a bit of a
cop-out you know like
you know because we uh the october
celebration is very much about the
indigenous peoples of you know united
states and canada and you know north
america so it's not about indigenous
people the rest of the world even though
they all have their own stories
if this bill practice passes we'd also
be breaking the general court would be
breaking 75 years of practice and
precedent
there is an unwritten rule but it's been
i think fairly unanimously it's been
quite faithfully followed that all bills
and resolutions
which say good things about the un
should be killed uh we're not and uh so
please uphold this tradition by itlling
hp 1173 or or alternatively amended to
the day which is actually celebrated
here in new hampshire which is the first
monday in october but i don't think the
time is ripe for that and that's um
and we have to ask answer any questions
if you'd like thank you are there any
questions representative schuett
thank you madam chair um
representative would you believe i was
curious during my lunch break
and i checked the sign ins on this bill
as of noon today
there were four supporters and 62
opposed that sounds about right i would
not be surprised no
and i'll uh
i'll sign in in opposition any other
representative pearson
he he didn't write the bill so i'm
i i have
i have concerns in line five of the
specific addressing of one native
american group
without over the over that of others
that that are from the region so i but
he's not the author oh let me
i mean i'm not here right that's fine
the concern has been mentioned
any other question to represent horrigan
seeing none thank you thank you
and i guess yes i do some written
testimony i can hand around and i'll
upload it to the website before midnight
so uh i am with rights on democracy i'm
also here
as a resident who lives in concord so a
new hampshire resident
i am here to speak against the spill and
i live in concord and my city just
recently passed indigenous peoples day
and i'm basically taking testimony that
i gave there and then presenting it here
dave did they pick as indigenous
people's day
uh
the
uh what is it called columbus day yep
you which i believe should be removed
um and not exist at all and i'll tell
you why
so the people we honor says a lot about
who we are as a community and about the
values we hold dear
honoring a man like columbus is neither
good for italian people indigenous
people or all of us in the state of new
hampshire
it is also a disservice to the students
who are being lied to by sending
messages that columbus has done good why
else would be would there be a holiday
to be named after him
i think it's really important that as a
community we change columbus day to
indigenous people's day as a correction
for past historical inaccuracies
as a libyan american i'd love to see the
day when people like me are celebrated
in this country
unlike the italians
who have been mostly accepted into
mainstream american culture we are
oftentimes stigmatized and made fun of
still but if a libyan participated in a
violent act the last thing i would want
to do is associate my culture
or my libyan pride with the violence nor
would i ever want a day associated with
a violent history caused by someone from
my culture to be used to celebrate us as
a people
as that really does not make sense in
logic
i believe we can move our communities
towards healing past mistakes and
teaching students and community members
that the project of america was a messy
one
and we must not run away from our past
mistakes we need to acknowledge them and
we can try to repair them
i am confident that we can do that as a
community so please
do not pass this we don't need another
day we can't be honoring violence
any questions
thank you are there any questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill
obviously not
all right in that case i'm going to
close the public hearing
and we have a few minutes before our
representative lucas
do we think we have a motion on the bill
uh
looks like everybody's back so yes
which bill
okay representative
lekis moves on to password amendment no
well first i guess we have to do the
amendment yeah i'm moving do we adopt um
amendment zero four eight seven h to
house bill
i'll give the clerk a minute here
the amendment is zero four eight seven h
and actually have copies of it
i emailed it but i think it
representative grota you want a second
okay
correct
madam chair who was the second
so now we've all had our papers shuffled
a representation speak to your motion
uh yes thank you um
there are a couple parts of this one
which we're
[Music]
um not changing that if people recall
this allows a uh
a real estate broker who um
performs some service which their
their contract would provide them with
deferred compensation compensation over
time could continue to receive that
compensation
even after
they were no longer active but the
amendment deals with
the licensure accepting licenses from
other jurisdictions
we had a discussion that there's if you
look on the original bill at on the
first page online 27 there's a section
that says this section applies to
non-resident salesperson and broker
applicants only
there was some discussion that there
were that word wasn't needed and
potentially caused problems
and um and so the amendment removes it
there were a couple there was a mix in
the bill of using the words uh taken and
passed with regard to tests
and there were two places where it was
taken and those were changed to pass
because
just taking a test doesn't necessarily
mean much
and the last was
changing the effective date from 60 to
90 days after passage
which came up at the hearing and and uh
oplc person uh
and that's it okay are there any
questions or actually represent growth
did you we should speak to your second
i just want to say that that these
changes were discussed during the
hearing and it seemed that the committee
was in favor of them
all right thank you
uh any questions represent fellows or
comments um this is a question because i
don't really understand
uh
show up like if i could
it seems to be representative lucas
thinks he has an answer okay
um
there are
art
and maybe uh representative grota can
help help as well but uh my
understanding is that
unless the same equivalence data is
currently always okay so it's it's
saying they're applying for a new
hampshire license
a real estate license uh which is
of a similar type as the one that they
have in another jurisdiction type of
status
the the point is that since it's a very
small state there may be people who live
in new hampshire who have been working
in massachusetts or maine or vermont and
now they want to get a new hampshire
that makes sense to me it just seems to
be written backwards
i would just think it would say
something like
if the applicant
the applicant qualifies in new hampshire
if he
holds
whatever yes it could it could
frequently be better written
but it does say
when they're applying for a new
hampshire license with the same
equivalent status
as currently licensed in the qualifying
jurisdiction so the jurisdiction where
they have existing yeah i guess i think
i guess
it's i would have said when they're
applying
well yeah
and their existing license is equivalent
to the one they're applying for
that's what it says
that okay that's fine representative
goalie
thank you madam chair just one quick
question because i'm looking at my notes
and i have down
that the recommended change was changing
the word non-resident on line 27 to
change it to recognition because that
was what they called it and i just want
to question the members of the
subcommittee if that was
deemed okay the way they wrote it
um yeah that was there was some further
discussion i think either at or after
the original hearing and the
subcommittee and and some email that
went
that we exchanged and that um
that taking the word out um
fixed the problem and that's
recognition was in in regard to
a different portion
well the section is recognition for
licensure yeah and it it it just wasn't
necessary and uh i mean could cause
confusion was the conclusion thank you
referring to line 27
on the original bill and i believe it
was representative fellowes
who said i think during the hearing
that you could just take that whole word
out that it didn't wasn't needed but
that's i recalled something like that
other questions
this is not to do with this but since
this executive session has anybody
noticed the quality of ols seems to be
not what it used to be
so many of these yes thank you
representative we don't have time for
yes
any other questions or comments concerns
okay then the motion is to adopt
amendment
0487h to house bill 1354.
representative rhodes
yes
clerk votes yes representative pearson
yes representative
yes
representative
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes
yes
representative goalie yes representative
show it
yes
representative horrigan
yes representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative
gomarlo yes
representative grota
yes representative o'brien
he stepped out i've stepped down
and uh the chair
yes 16 uh no no
yeah i'd better
2 4
eight ten twelve four two two eighteen
to zero
okay the motion passes eighteen to zero
uh representative lucas you have a
motion yes i'd like to uh move ought to
pass as amended or with amendment on
house bill 1354.
second okay by representative lekkis
this one seconded by representative
grota
any further comment or question
she was louder and faster i think the
prior discussion
covered it unless someone has questions
is there any discussion
well seeing none the motion is ought to
pass with amendment on house bill 1354
and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes yes
clerk wrote cs representative pearson
yes
representative lekkis yes representative
allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lanzaro yes
representative santo nestaso
yes
representative goalie
representative schuett
yes
representative horrigan
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative gamarlo yes
all right the motion passes 18 to zero
okay seeing none we'll put it on consent
who finally seconded road
road
o'brien back okay we've got a full house
we're going to do the pension
okay
sure
lost
we have some comm i have some scheduling
updates for you
next
we have hearings next monday and tuesday
in fact on monday
actually we on monday we have one
hearing in the morning
and on tuesday we have three hearings in
the afternoon and those are the last of
our
first committee bills yay verily
and then we'll have an executive session
toward the end of the month or possibly
even the first week of march the
deadline is march 10th
subcommittees are free to schedule
whenever you like
i would suggest starting
sooner rather than later because it's
quite possible we'll be getting some
second committee bills
and
bills from the senate in fact they just
passed a whole slug of them yes on last
week
so
plan your your workload
uh i'm i'm only expecting to have one
formal executive session toward the end
yes representative
yes ma'am sure do you have any kind of a
feeling as to how many
second committee house bills we are
likely to get
no and
so that my recommendation if you see a
licensing bill
or coming from another committee you
vote against it that way we won't get it
and they have to pass that advice
they have to pass the house to come to
us we'll undoubtedly get some but i
being three o'clock i opened the public
hearing on
a non-jermaine amendment the house bill
representative lackas
thank you i'm representative lucas
hillsborough 37 representing the towns
of hudson and pelham
and i'm introducing amendment 0375h
what this amendment does is very simple
it repeals
rsa
126-bb which in effect
eliminates the prescription drug
bringing this member amendment forward
for also this was heard before our
subcommittee and
the subcommittee voted to
support the amendment three to two
so a little bit of history on
how the prescription drug advisory board
came to be
it was created by the 2022 2020 bill
house bill 1280 and that bill came to
the house as a straightforward bill
dealing with co-payments for insulin
however when it came back from the
senate it had been turned into an
omnibus bill including i think it was at
least seven different topics
and while the house uh just didn't
concur i mean there was no committee of
conference or anything just a straight
concur with the senate version
that year the bill had no public hearing
in the house
it was not considered by any house
committee so the house did not have an
opportunity to give this complicated
bill uh proper consideration
i think there's a number of issues
with the board
the board has the power to basically in
effect engage in
fixing prices for prescription drugs
purchased by public payers
i mean they don't set the price but if
they're not satisfied with the price
they get
they can make such drugs unavailable uh
through a public pair thereby
prohibiting patients from receiving
drugs that their doctors consider uh
best for them or at least they won't get
paid for
the board is charged with the pot it's
given the power to
create a database with a range of
information on prescription drugs
pricing and other things
and it can require pairs providers
prescription drug manufacturers
wholesale drug distributors
you know pharmacy benefit managers and
others to provide that information
and not only can the board require those
entities to provide the data the board's
then empowered to sell that data which i
thought was kind of interesting
the board also has the power to assess
fees from many entities related to
prescription drugs
the information i got so there's
approximately
1700 entities subject to a 500 fee and
other entities or can be assessed a fee
of not less than a hundred dollars
the total effect of what these these are
in effect taxes the board will collect
is estimated
i've seen between eight hundred and
fifty thousand one point two million and
i
some of reigns said it could reach up to
two million
and the bill would create a non-lapsing
dedicated fund for this money the board
raise and spend without
oversight by you know legislature
fiscal committee governor council or
anybody else
and the other one is the board is
permitted to meet and deliberate
maintenance in secret because the
statute exempts them from the
requirements of rsa 91a except that
any decision of the board shall be made
in you know made public once they made
their decision but not the process
and neither the board nor the advisory
council which is an advisor advisory to
the board are permitted to have any
representatives from
drug you know producers providers uh you
know who could present represent their
views um to the board
and then there's you know
it's a further question of is the board
actually necessary
and it turns out the departments of
insurance and health and human services
have been collecting
very similar prescription drug data for
over a decade
and the department of administrative
services is currently authorized to
conduct a reverse auction process
to achieve lower prescription drug
prices for health insurance plans
administered by the state
and das has already successfully done so
i actually got a call back from
the
director commissioner um arlene house
charlie arlinghaus
about what they've been doing in this
area and they've been very active
in working to keep prescription drug
prices down they're monitoring what's
going on out of their states
even in cases where they're not doing
reverse auctions
they are
putting these out to bid and they have
gotten certainly lower prices as a
result
and
you know they're doing a variety of
things
around
purchasing and bidding
to
you know reduce the cost to the state of
the prescription drugs for these
programs so
um
i see problems with how the board was
created
the powers the board has and i don't
believe it's actually necessary which is
why i'm proposing to abolish the board
thank you
thank you are there any questions for
representative bleckis
representative marsh
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative lancaster for taking my
question uh as you and i both know this
language originally began in senate bill
687 and as we also know governor sununu
issued a press release on march 11 2020
in which he stated this bill will create
a drug affordability board in new
hampshire to monitor changes in the cost
of prescription drugs to keep the
industry honest and to keep an eye on
prices to prevent price spikes often
many of the challenges in health care
can start to be addressed through
greater transparency and pricing that
transparency brings scrutiny and
accountability as to why the cost of a
particular drug is high or higher than
similar drugs i look forward to signing
the spill into law
given that that was the statement
governor sununu made about this language
i'm wondering what governor sununu's
opinion of your amendment is you would
have to ask the governor i cannot speak
for him
thank you any other questions
representative
horrigan um yes thank you very much mr
chair thank you mr representative
blackist i was
peeking at the docket for the bill so
the senate uh passed it and sent it um
over the wall which in that case was 35
miles wide because they're meeting here
perhaps all we're beating
yes so what
and uh
and then when we next time we met we
approved the conference uh committee
report so what
what should we have done differently
back then and the conference committee
court you know passed with a very broad
bipartisan margin but um so
what should we do morgan one thing we
should have done was reject this bill
because our rules forbid us from
accepting from the other body
as part of the committee of conference
procedure a new fee that has not had a
hearing in the house and these fees
thank you representative lackas
here we go
thank you madam chair for the record my
name is peter leishman i represent
hillsboro 24 which is peterborough
so i can't really add much more than the
sponsors of the amendment from hudson
just spoke to but
as the chair knows i'm very much a
process person and when the request came
to the fiscal committee
several
weeks back for the authorization
to have some funding for an executive
director and so forth i did a little
digging because i really hadn't paid
much attention to this particular
board until it came to if you will my
headlights
and
when i learned that never had the proper
hearing in the house that fees were
established
without a thorough house review i
learned of the representatives amendment
just a day or two ago and i thought i
should come and at least support that
amendment because this is totally
contrary to the feelings i've always had
as far as
a real public review of any legislation
whether it be fees or a new board so
that's why i'm here to support the
amendment
thanks madam chair
thank you representative are there any
questions
okay
thank you for your testimony senator
sherman
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
senator tom sherman
district 24 along the seacoast
um
i wanted to
talk just a little bit
about the prescription drug
affordability board i was prime sponsor
of the bill that introduced it
i was approached by aarp and new futures
and others
to see if we could do this in the state
of new hampshire
this is something that's not new it's
already enacted in maine and maryland
the point of the bill was part of
actually three bills at the time that
one would have been the reverse auction
bill that the sponsor of the amendment
mentioned so that was also part of that
omnibus bill
as was the bill that allowed us to do
reimportation of pharmaceuticals from
canada
the reason behind these bills is that
one of the biggest costs
to patients i'm a physician
so to patients and to the state has has
to do with prescription drugs
so what the p dab or prescription drug
affordability by the way it is the word
is affordability board
the goal there is to
make the state
as smart a consumer as possible
it doesn't
regulate which medicines are available
but it looks at
and if you look at the in the rsa if you
look at the
powers and duties of the board
first of all and i think this is very
important the board shall identify
strategies that optimize spending by
public payers that's us
for pharmaceutical products while
reasonably ensuring subscriber access
that's to make sure the drugs are
available to people who need them
to needed pharmaceutical prod
products
the second point is that the board shall
determine spending targets on specific
specific prescription drugs that may
cause affordability challenges to enroll
enrollees in a public payer health plan
the board shall determine which public
payers are likely to exceed the spending
targets determined on the paragraph
and then they make recommendations
none of this tries to control pricing
that is just not true
we can't
that's interstate commerce and it's
so what do we do well first of all the
bill passed
in the senate
by
virtually a unanimous bipartisan vote
the members of the board include senator
carson
several physicians
governor appointees
the bill that was brought to you 1566
was really to address some housekeeping
items that have come
up as ones that we need to really look
at in terms of attracting
leadership or
the goal of the board is to optimize the
cost to the state by understanding the
prescription drug environment our
utilization as a public payer
and how to decrease state costs
there's nothing surreptitious about this
and literally the board has spent
20 30 hours
in meeting time to try to get started or
more
and one of the other points that was
made was that all this or a lot of this
is being done in secret that is not true
the only portions of this that can be
done in secret are actually to protect
the pharmaceuticals because some of the
information that they're providing is
proprietary so we have developed a way
that they can send us the proprietary
information
and then that we can meet
uh without
any public disclosure because
to do so would actually be to give away
their trade secrets which we're very
protective of and that's the way the
so i think part of the drive of this and
i understand
representative leishman's concerns about
due process or the process that was done
and yours as well madam chair
but i would ask you
to look at the merits of what
the prescription drug affordability
board is trying to do which is decreased
state costs
we don't have any impact on pricing
we don't have any impact on
how
a drug is marketed we don't have any
impact on whether or not they can market
it whether they can give rebates any of
those
what we do have the ability to do as a
board is to understand all of that
environment the best as we can so that
the state has the lowest prescription
drug pricing and costs
as possible
while still having that availability and
accessibility
so i hope
understanding that there were process
issues because of the pandemic that we
can
find a way to move forward with the
amendment with the original bill and the
housekeeping items that were in that
bill
and again not
destroy all the work that's been done to
date
and also make sure that we can go ahead
as the state as the state which is one
of the largest consumers if not the
largest consumer of prescription drugs
in the in the state of new hampshire
that we can be as smart as possible in
this very complex environment
so with that i'll take any questions
thank you
senator sherman
it was indicated
in previous testimony that
the department of health and human
services is already collecting similar
data
can you comment on how that
data collection would differ from what
your the board is doing
right what um hhs collects data on
medicaid patients um and prescription
drug utilization by medicaid patients
um that's not what this board is
designed to look at
what this board is trying to look at is
other systems that
are utilizing this such as
state
um state employees and others that are
funded through the state or through
so
uh
you were
listing i'm sure intently when
representative marsh uh read the
governor's statement
and
so
representationman's
privacy concerns or
process concerns are obviously things
that we as house members have some
responsibility to
adhere to
but
the governor has a say in
this in
this
process as well do we know whether the
governor has taken a position on this
amendment
i
thank you for the question by the way i
also was a house member so i i get it i
was in the house from 2012 to 2016.
um
and
and i when i was a house member i was
also fiercely
defending the rights of the house but i
will remind the house members
that this was something that could have
been concurred with or not concurred
with and
if there was a problem with that i'd
much rather address
go back look at the issues that might
have been raised rather than
really throwing out
to answer your question the governor
signed in in support of the original
bill
and i'm sure he will
be surprised since he has
representatives on the prescription drug
affordability affordability board i
think he would be surprised that people
are trying to take away something that
is
very likely not only to improve access
but also decrease fund decrease costs to
the state
thank you for that answer i would like
to caution the committee that
speculating on the motives of other
people is not an appropriate question
we've done it's been done twice and i
will not let it happen again
uh
if you have anyone has actually received
a communication from the governor saying
i support this amendment or i'm opposed
to this amendment that's a fact and
we'll be glad to hear it but i would not
i will not listen to any more
speculation on that thank you
and i i will not speculate on that in
the future as well thank you
other questions
representative lekkis correct
thank you um
well as i stated i agree and i agree
with you that the board doesn't have the
power to do price fixing
um
i was what i was referring to is in 126
bb5 in the rsas
roman 3
there's a couple of pieces in here the
board has the power
changing a formulary when sufficient
rebates cannot be as
secured under some paragraph a
and i mean
and uh prohibiting health insurance
carriers in the state administering
benefits for a public payer from
offering on their formularies
prescription drugs when the method
described above is implemented so i mean
is it not i mean do you disagree that
that in effect makes drugs where they
can't get the price they want
unavailable
actually they don't have the power to if
you read the paragraph above that under
paragraph three what it says is
while continuing to ensure adequate
access by subscribers to needed
prescribed pharmaceutical products
the board shall determine whether the
following methods reduce costs to
individuals purchasing prescription
drugs through a public payer and allow
public payers to meet the spending
targets established under paragraph one
it's not saying that the board can
actually do that
it's saying
and it's written right here
the board shall determine whether the
following methods reduce costs it
doesn't say the board shall do this
it can make a recommendation but it
doesn't
tell them what to do and what not to do
and and i think that's one of the
misunderstandings of what this board
this board is not
a regulatory body
this board
is an information gathering body so that
the state payers can be as smart as
possible
and then if the state payers have higher
costs than one might anticipate based on
this
increased knowledge that the board
has
then it can identify
those and go back and talk with the
state payers it would be similar
if i if if i prescribe something to a
patient i have patients who go
they know exactly what the drug is they
know what the generics are they know
whether there's a
rebate form attached to it
they do all of the research on their own
and it's not easy if you've ever been a
patient and you've been prescribed a
drug it's not easy to know what's
available and what's not available there
are coupons there are plastic cards
there are discount cards there are all
sorts of cards
this makes the state
that smart patient
and that smart patient saves a lot of
money when it comes to prescription
drugs i can prescribe a drug
called remicade
that can cost a patient five six
thousand dollars for that
drug they can get the generic for two
the administration of the drug
could cost another
two to three thousand dollars
but the smart patient goes and works
with their insurance company or whoever
it is to make sure the delivery method
is as
low cost as possible exact same
formulation
and does the same thing
but thousands of dollars cheaper
so
what we're suggesting by taking away the
prescription drug affordability board
which by the way does not use any state
funds
it's not a tax we have many fees we have
park fees we have many fees out there
this uses fees to be
as smart as possible to save the state
money
that's what this is about it's about
making the state a smart patient just
like my smart patients are saving
multiple thousands of dollars when they
know exactly how to
use a prescription properly and how to
all right
okay thank you
any other questions representative
goalie and then fellow
thank you madam chair i think this
question would probably be addressed to
you if i may
um the original bill we had dealt with a
subject matter that pertained to edna
dealing with
classified unclassified positions
the non-german amendment we have before
us now
i believe pertains to
subject matter that should be in front
of health and human services committee
not edna
and
as we talk about process we are once
again in a process of
subject matter before this committee
that we tend to not delve into
and i know it's a second committee but i
don't think health and human services is
a second committee to send this to no
but it is possible for the second
committee to be changed i know that
house bill 1288 which we exact earlier
was not an early bill until we attached
the non-germain amendment and now it's
going to finance i agree with you that
this bill should
worry to pass the amendment and pass the
bill go on to health and human services
well
the reason i'm asking my this question
is because i'm not a person who's
familiar with this subject and that's
why it's so difficult for me to
understand but my question is
the the public pay the public payers
that are covered by
whatever information this board might
come up with includes places like towns
and school districts
also
and the way you've just described it
somehow
is the objective that somehow
they can
see that information or
to to understand that they can that
they're going to prescribe in their
insurance company in coverage to that
one
the generic is better than the other or
why isn't this why don't doctors have
access to this information so they
prescribe the generic to begin with one
of just how is this going to work
so
i would love it if you wanted to come to
one of our
meetings
prescription drug pricing prescription
drug
coupons i mean we've had bills here in
front of the house and over in front of
the senate
for years trying to figure out how do we
do this
and the answer is it's complicated
it takes
a hugely dedicated effort
to really understand this environment
i would wager that
many of us in the medical profession
don't fully understand how prescription
drug pricing works
and we've had actually lectures in in on
the board i sit on the board i'm not
chair but i sit on the board
and it's been eye-opening for me and to
think that patients have to go through
this
to figure out how to save money
is mind-boggling
so what this
does
and one of the things you you hit on
which is really important this isn't
likely to just save state money this is
likely to decrease property taxes
so the the sponsor of the repeal
i hope he will understand
that the smarter you get
as a patient
whether you how you pick your doctor
you know how many people go to get a
colonoscopy
and know that
a good colon i'm a gastroenterologist we
follow how good i am
at doing colonoscopies we follow what's
called adenoma detection rate which is
how often the polyps i remove
have a pre-cancerous cell in them
did you know that only two gi groups in
the entire state do that
and one of them is dartmouth which is a
we follow how often
or how long it takes a doctor to pull
the colonoscope out of the colon
because the data shows that if it's
under six minutes they're not spending
enough time in your colon and they're
going to miss colon cancers did you know
that
do you ask your gi doc when you go in
for your screening colonoscopy what's
your adenoma detection rate and
you know how many
how what's your scope withdrawal time no
this is even more complicated
the state
whether it's department of health and
human services which has no
designated
program to do that analysis although we
tried a long time ago
the department of insurance has no
designated program to do that analysis
nor do they have the capacity
and department of administrative
services
their reverse auction was in the same
bill
that you all concurred with
and it's being touted as a great bill
so the point i'm making is this is
really complicated the benefit to the
state
this is not going to hurt patients or i
guarantee you the physicians that were
helping with this would not be
supporting it because that's my first
priority is my patients
but what it does is it makes the state a
smarter consumer
lower state costs that's the goal
lowers municipal costs
and that translates into lower property
taxes
so i appreciate the question the answer
is
this will have a huge impact
if you think of what proportion of our
state cost goes towards prescription
thank you
one short follow-up yeah
so one of my questions is
does every state have to do this on
their own because the costs are
different from state to state
yes
thank you that was a short answer
i appreciate it representative marsh uh
thank you madam chairman thank you
senator sherman for coming before us
today i ask this as a true informational
question because i don't know the answer
as you know i'm also a retired physician
but i retired five years ago and five
years ago when i was doing electronic
prescribing which was newer than it is
now there was no data presented to your
doctor as to the cost of the various
alternative medicines that they could
prescribe
so there was really no way for a
physician to do what representative
fellows said that is to compare the cost
of alternative modes of treatment has
anything been done to increase
transparency to physicians in the
interim time
not in my experience
thank you
any other questions
representative grota
i think it's going to be short
so when you're making when you're buying
a table
there's a supply chain
that you can analyze and you can analyze
how much the raw materials are how much
it costs to make the table how much it
costs to paint the table how much it
costs to sell the table table table
to a
walmart or
you know there's there are costs
associated with all along the way that
supply chain
so are we
is there such is there a similar
supply chain
for pharmaceuticals
or is it
is that is that analogy
inappropriate
there is a supply chain
but it
for the same
medication it could go through multiple
different routes
with multiple different levels of
pricing
you know whether it's wholesalers pbms
so the short answer is
yes but remember
one of the things that the board has
access to
because it has that confidential
confidentiality component is it has
access to the supply chain
on the proprietary side so
that's why it's so important
to have the board because
dhhs
can't even have access to that
proprietary information
department of insurance
can't necessarily have access to that
proprietary information but this board
can
and it can't change the prices it can't
change the coupons it can't change any
of that
this is not
anything standing in the way of free
market this is standing in the way
in the setting of a smart consumer
being able to fully understand the
market
and then make their purchases as wisely
as possible
you madam chair
i work for the city of manchester and
the city of manchester being
self-insured has a substantial vested
interest in keeping their costs down as
a municipality when one of the programs
that they offer is something called the
smart shopper which you may or may not
be familiar with but okay so
in that what that does is that
incentivizes me as a end user
to
potentially go with a lower cost option
and i'm subsequently rewarded for
potential choices that that fall under
that okay and i'm in an hsa and that i'm
paying out of paying it anyway and that
that benefits me as well is there
anything going on in
this world
similar to smart chopper when it comes
to prescription drugs where people can
say hey
i got a chart if i get it at rite aid
versus you know joe's online versus
whatever where i am now steered towards
solving my problem of the
filling a prescription i need but also
doing it in a way where
i can
utilize the free market economy and
choose the lowest cost does that exist
like anywhere like it does for smart
shopper for mammography or
those various things
uh so
what you last said about mammography
there is something the new hampshire
insurance department has a new hampshire
health cost website
which by the way tyler brannon developed
on his own and it has won national
awards
and it uses utilization data to actually
figure out what the actual costs are to
the patient so that if if you needed a
colonoscopy you could go to that website
and it would tell you
you know where in the state that's for
procedures and
and x-rays and things like that and
there's a code attached to those so it's
really pretty easy for them to say
okay for this code what are all the
prices around the state
and tyler's
you know amazing work just here in new
hampshire
but i don't know of anything on the
prescription drug side
that has that kind of
affordability
or the you know remember the complexity
of it is
there are as i mentioned there are cards
discount cards there are rebate systems
so you almost don't know until you have
the prescription in hand
what all your options are and there's no
great you know sort of one-stop shopping
like smart shopper where you can do that
thank you madam chair
is that
with that leading to
[Music]
consumer savings right right because i
don't really care who trucked it and
i
i guess i care that you bought it at
rite aid but i'll plug my wife's
employer here but
um
you know the particulars of that
irrelevant to me right i'm just the guy
that's got to pay and buy this i got to
fill this prescription so is is that
type of of end consumer benefit part of
what this board would ever be involved
in or is that an end goal of this board
or how does that even tie into this
board's world in any way
the short answer is my belief is
no
because this is really focused on the
state and the state costs
could a similar board be constructed
to to do what you're
describing um
you know i'm not sure you could
unless it were
federal
legislation or something in a much
broader scale
i just don't know how somebody could get
access to all that data representative
pearson you might ask your insurance
company because i know mine does that
they they say if you buy this drug at
walmart it's one price if you buy it at
rite aids this is what the price is
right if i could just add to that
the insurance company is a great
reference for this
but if you are uninsured one thing about
the new hampshire
[Music]
health cost
website is that it has both insured and
uninsured costs on it so
it really depends on your insurance and
and you know everybody's insurance
benefit is different and the insurance
companies might contract with a
different pbm or they might have their
own internal ppm that's why it's so hard
to do with prescription drugs and and
really that's the environment that this
board is trying to understand on behalf
of the state
representative goalie did you have a
question
just a real brief question if i may i
don't know if the doctor can answer this
or not but
is there instances out there where
those consumers that don't have
insurance
can actually get a cheaper product than
what
a pharmacy may be charging an insurance
typically those without insurance i mean
i can go one on one to a pharmaceutical
and say i need this for this patient and
there will be
compassionate care protocols within that
company to get it either for free or at
a sharp discount if that's what you're
asking
it for me it it my experience has always
been one-on-one so
if i have a patient who can't afford it
doesn't have insurance i will go to the
pharmaceutical and see if we can get it
on a compassionate level or some kind of
they have all of the pharmaceuticals
um
waiting for the
okay
so
representative i believe that we are
ready for you thank you for your
patience
and thank you madam chair
for the
record my name is
gary merchant i represented sullivan
county district 4 which is ward 2 in
claremont new hampshire
and also for the record i chair the
prescription drug affordability board
here in new hampshire
i come before you today to oppose
amending
which would repeal
bb the prescription drug affordability
board
prior to serving in the new hampshire
house representatives
i served on the new hampshire board of
pharmacy for 10 years
the last two years as president of the
board
many of my 40-plus years as a pharmacist
was spent working in this complex
complicated non-transparent pharmacy
supply chain
attaches an overview of the various
entities within the pharmacy supply
chain
if you look at the diagram
what i want to point out to you folks
collectively
it's not straightforward
if you want to look at the
flow of the dollar it's different than
the flow of the drug itself
there are many players that are involved
with the pricing of the prescription
drug
from the
manufacturer to the pbm
the wholesaler
as well as the pharmacy and the
because of the complexity
of what we have before you
it took me 30 some odd years to begin to
really understand this
and who the players are um i mean it
without sincerity
i worked with dartmouth hitchcock
in the pharmaceutical supply chain with
over a quarter of a billion dollars a
year in contracts this is a complex area
and if you don't know how to navigate it
you're going to have a problem because
you're going to basically have the issue
of buyer beware
so if you don't have an educated buyer
before you
whether it be a hospital which i
represented at that time or a patient
the system is stacked against them
there's too many parts to it that truly
to give you another example
a recent report by the berkeley research
group
showed in 2023
67 percent
of the gross expenditures brand
branded prescription drugs went to the
manufacturer 67 percent folks
in 2020
that's now down to less than 50 percent
that's a 25 percent decrease the
manufacturers are taking in
on their bottom line to pay for their
cost of services
the other one i showed you is the one
from lily
we always talk about insulin i thought
this is important to the committee
if you look at the graph in 2016 the
list price which is what we base
the price that the patients on
five years later it increased to 275
dollars for that vial
however
the net price to the manufacturer went
from 59 down to 50.
so i would ask this committee along with
what we're trying to do here at the
prescription drug affordability award
where what is going on
why are drug prices paid by patients
increasing while net prices and
manufacturers are decreasing
where is the money going
the legislation passed in 2020 was to
try to help the state navigate these
chartered waters
to bring transparency to the system
for the state
another study which was recently
produced in 2020 2018
by the university of southern california
showed you look back at the numbers
that the patients overpaid
on their prescriptions 23 of the time
23 of the time by almost eight dollars
why
i don't have the answer
but the goal of the prescription drug
affordability board is to find the
answers
to help the patients to help the state
navigate this complex
system
in regards to a couple of things we
talked about before
there is no pricing authority in this
the us constitution
commerce clause prohibits states from
setting pricing
in regards to confidentiality as senator
sherman said
a lot of the data we're trying to obtain
from them to better understand what is
going on
is predicated upon prior to proprietary
data
that needs to remain confidential
and therefore
it needs to remain in that capacity
to invite other members to the board to
have a vested interest in what we're
doing
we'd be counterproductive no one would
share with the board the information if
they have representation from
other competing
entities within supply chain including
pharma pbms and so forth
regards to the dollars that we're
talking about
the initial estimate we had before the
board
was 1700
entities
that came from the office of
professional licensure and certification
that was based upon a permit they
issued to wholesalers manufacturers
brokers
virtual manufacturers and so forth there
was no breakout
by energy
which one was which
after going to new hampshire department
of medicaid
we were able to get a cleaner list of
actual manufacturers which once we took
care of the duplicates was less than 500
there's probably another 100 or maybe
less of wholesalers so the total that
we're looking for is probably 600.
so the number we're looking for which
went the fiscal committee was 300
000 350 000 not 850 000 to 1.8 1.2
million
to give you a feel for how this is so
non-transparent
in january
of this year
the attorney general's office settled
with santeen which is a pbm
which operates our medicaid managed care
organization
do you have any clue what they settled
for
21 million dollars
in 2021 the same company settled with
ohio for over 88 million
where's the money going folks
as
senator sherman said and also
synchronous march said
governor sununu released a statement
after the past the senate
that this is probably one of the ways to
bring greater accountability and greater
transparency to an opaque system
to help the state fundamentally be sure
it's getting as much of its savings as
it possibly can
if we don't know how it works
we don't understand the mechanism the
levers behind it
how is the state going to maximize its
opportunity to save money
be without that information
that's just the state itself but think
about it this way too
we're all policy makers
don't we want to have accurate
information before us
to make correct policy decisions
without the information without that
so i leave you with this
the journey from a manufacturer to the
patient passes through many entities
by a complicated
complex non-transparent path
often to the detriment of the patient
and the public payers
our primary goal of the prescription
drug affordability board is to bring
greater transparency
on the pricing of prescription drugs to
ensure
that the state of new hampshire and
other public payers
save valuable healthcare dollars for
both the government and with the
patients
thank you representative are there
questions
representative marsh
uh thank you uh mr madam chairman and
thank you representative for taking my
question
my question regards this chart that you
handed out
am i correct that this is uh the slide
that we used at the prescription drug
affordability board to describe the
pharmaceutical
supply chain as representative grota
asked earlier and that we spent several
hours trying to understand this
particular supply chain at the
prescription drug affordability board
representative marsh that is actually
right this is the chart we reviewed it's
the chart i spent 30 years of my life
trying to understand and quite frankly i
think i've got it but i'm totally
telling you now i don't think i totally
understand it that's after 30 years of
looking at it
questions
uh thank you madam chair i um
for the record i'm representative jess
edwards uh representing auburn chester
and sandown and i'm not i'm not here
today to
to be a subject matter expert you've
heard a lot of testimony from people who
uh know this subject a lot better than i
have
so so what am i going to do i'm going to
tell you
my experience with
this affordability board and sort of my
reactions to it and hope that in some
way you can relate to my kind of
human experience
i'm a member of the joint fiscal
committee
and it is in our most recent fiscal
committee meeting that we
saw a proposal
to
authorize transfers of funds so that the
affordability board could have i believe
it was 350 000
and
during that presentation the dhhs
individual who was
presenting the the proposal
actually knew very little about the
proposal and
is going to come back with additional
information
but the things that just jumped out to
me was getting the affordability board
going
it was they were not at all clear on
what their cash flow situation was going
to be
and
and to me as a person who's managed
operations i think understanding your
cash flow is a good indication of
understanding what you're doing and they
the
the expert from dhhs could not explain
it
um
also um
the
they talked about
needing to hire an executive director
but it wasn't clear what that process
would be like
they wanted to make sure they could
start collecting fees
and if you're a person paying a fee
it feels like a tax
so the semantics around fees are not
taxes
and that fees represent no cost to the
government
uh i i hope i hope we understand what's
really going on when you collect a new
fee to the business that's paying the
fee
that feels like a tax
and those
taxes
would be fees i'll stick to the official
word because i think the point is clear
that there's very little real
distinction of of
importance between a fee and a tax but
it's a fee um i would say that um those
fees are coming from the industry
from which this affordability board
wants to find ways
to reduce their prices
and
i just think as a common sense sort of
thing
you don't initiate an increase in
supplier's price structure
and then say good now you can reduce
your prices if you increase their costs
you're increasing their prices that's
the way things work
and so we've heard today a bunch of
potential benefits
to the state to include reduction of
property taxes
okay so i would just simply say
that the benefits
that are being
promised
are theoretical
and what we know is real is they want to
add
to our supply system
at least a 350 000 a year
set attack fees excuse me
so uh let's go to some other good
government principles
the house did not
hear
the details of this we didn't get a
chance to work through it
the other house
did an omnibus bill
i personally hate
omnibus bills i think every bill needs
to be looked at i think the other house
looks at us
as
the body that has
more people
and more time to do the deep dive on
things and we've had
a tremendous number of questions both in
the joint fiscal committee and i'm as
i'm hearing today
um about
um what the real impact of this bill uh
this uh board would be
i i would just point out that
in law we have the
new hampshire
prescription drug competitive
marketplace
section
21-i dash or colon 96
and in it the purpose and intent is to
optimize prescription drug savings
by the state of new hampshire this is
what we heard earlier from
the representative from hudson
that mr arlinghaus has already done
some work in and has already produced a
reverse
auction
please don't ask me what a reverse
auction is i i'm not not prepared to
answer that but it's one of the key
tools also being used by the
affordability bill
so
there's a level of redundancy that i
think
exists in the affordability bill
that
affordability board
bill that that i i think really deserves
to have the house
do a deep dive before we really
authorize this thing to crank up
because
the general statement that we're going
to grow government we're going to
increase taxes
and we're going to come up with nirvana
at the other end of it just sounds to me
to be a little optimistic
it's also noteworthy that they're able
to collect their fees
and change their fees and waive their
fees
outside of the legislature and
one of the things i think the
legislature should guard jealously
is
our ability to control the purse strings
and so we've set up this board
that can operate very autonomously
with a lot of
secrecy
and it isn't really clear to me
where we would get the accountability so
uh i would suggest that um
we go ahead and or you go ahead please
uh let me correct that you go ahead and
seriously consider
representative lucas's amendment
this affordability board was was built
in the darker night as far as the house
was concerned and that we we really
seriously need to take a deep dive on
this and yes it's complicated
i've heard several times that this is
very complicated but so it just seems to
me
all the more justification for us to
step back take a deep breath and get it
right so
um i'll i'll answer questions if there
uh not seeing any thank you very much
good afternoon madam chair honorable
members of committee my name is jake
berry i'm the vice president of policy
at new futures as many of you know new
futures is a nonpartisan nonprofit
health policy and advocacy organization
we work extensively with policy makers
service providers and
families across the granite state to
increase access to quality affordable
i don't want to repeat too much of what
has been said
this afternoon i have passed out my
written testimony for you all to read at
your leisure
but i do want to stress new future
strong strong strong opposition to this
amendment
simply put we are in uh the rising cost
of prescription drugs is nothing less
than a public health crisis in this
state and across the country and the
affordability board is is an important
tool to help bring increased
transparency transparency and
accountability
to these uh to the rising cost of drugs
in the last few years alone we have seen
we have seen the cost of insulin rise
more than 50 percent we have seen the
cost of
narcan rise more than 400 percent in the
midst of an ongoing addiction crisis i
should note we have seen epipen rise
more than 400 percent we have seen all
across the board uh the average cost of
prescription drugs has gone up more than
five times the the rate of inflation uh
these are costs that hit new hampshire
families hard we have see you know these
are our decreasing access to these
life-saving treatments we are seeing
patients having to
uh having to forego treatment or having
to ration their medications
these are making people less healthy
people
and you know when the people have to
ration or or not uh not you not take
their medications as prescribed they end
up in the hospital in emergency rooms
this increase the cost of uncompensated
care which
comes back down to
to all of us healthcare consumers in
terms of higher premiums and other
healthcare costs
again i would stress that this
affordability board is a really
important tool to just bring to light
more about what this process looks like
why these costs are going up so high
and and maybe can begin to come up with
some recommendations about how we can
better address them and bring bring this
needed relief to new hampshire families
given all the uh all the public health
concerns we are facing uh at this time
i'm frankly i'm a little surprised that
we are
that we are considering this this is an
important tool we should support it and
keep it in place and allow it to do its
work and with that i'm happy to take
questions
thank you mr mr berry are there
questions from the committee
representative grota
thank you madam chair mr berry um how
does this board
we've we've heard that
das is already doing this and the
department of health and human services
is already doing this how does in your
view how does this differ from what's
already being done in the state sure
thank you for the question
representative and certainly there are
others in the room who have spent more
time with the board and can talk a
little more about the mechanics than i
can but you know i think that the data
collection the research that they are
that this board is able to conduct with
the uh you know with the backing of the
state is just i think it
um uh uh you know it outweighs the you
know what we're able to do elsewhere i
think that the board is uh you know this
stat it is made up of uh professionals
and export experts in this area um i
ideally you know
based on the underlying bill you're
considering it would have staff in place
to be able to uh to do this research
collect this data and bring shine more
light on uh sort of the the the
practices and the approaches that
pharmaceutical companies are taking
so uh you know i i think it really is uh
you know an important an important tool
for all of us and and uh um yeah i i
think that we the more tools we have in
thank you
seeing none thank you mr berry
thank you madam chair members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
mike padmar i'm the director of advocacy
for the new hampshire medical society
um i'll be relatively brief because i
think that a number of the folks who
have testified before me including mr
berry have touched on a lot of the
things that i want to implore to all of
you today but but i'm here today to
speak in opposition uh to the
non-jermaine amendment zero three seven
five h to hb one five six six fn uh two
years ago the new hampshire medical
society we joined a bipartisan group of
lawmakers and statewide stakeholders to
pass
hb 1280 that enacted this prescription
drug affordability board
we represent physicians
across the board this is something that
i spoke with them about
in when we were working on this bill a
few years ago and just across the board
this was something that our physicians
saw a need to have
a dedicated body to to look into this
from their perspective they don't see
this work being done
a number of things have been listed
today of other entities that are trying
to accomplish what this board is doing
and frankly
from their perspective they haven't seen
the results of that
so this board what it's attempting to do
um
our health care providers want this work
to be done our patients their patients
want this work to be done don't don't
stop this body this board from trying to
accomplish this goal which i think from
the folks who have spoken before me have
outlined just a number of things that
would benefit our state
and the patients that live here
so with that i thank you all for your
time and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you are there any questions
representative scitec
how do we measure the effectiveness and
board i
thank you for the question uh
to be honest sir uh i i'm i'm not
certain other than we're going to uh
look at the goals that they have
outlined in it and i think that as we
as the board is able to do their work
i think that those results will be known
we'll we'll see
whether or not
there is further transparency what what
some of our patients are are able to
um if they're able to utilize some of
these different things
but i think that the the the intent of
this board
is good
and i think that we have seen support
through uh the committee process two
years ago of stakeholders coming
including the governor
stating their support for the intent
of what this bill will do
you're talking about the results
we may not know those results for a bit
but
but i think that if the goals are are
good and if the goals are smart then we
should give this board an opportunity to
other questions
yes representative groat and then
marshall thank you madam chair where
would the
reports of
meetings and
of this board be found
i'm sorry did you say where would they
be
i don't know if i can specifically
answer that question but i i believe
that one of the folks who testified i
believe it was senator sherman may have
addressed that question but i i'm not
certain but i i can certainly check with
senator sherman and i can certainly
check with
who's the representatives questionnaire
is a member of the board and if he isn't
able to the question answer the question
i would be surprised sure
uh thank you for that madam chair i have
a copy of the 2021 annual report in my
hands right now it was issued november
1st 2021 uh i
can try to find out where that's
available on the web but if anybody
wants a copy i'd be glad to hand it to
somebody who can make copies for the
entire uh committee if they so desire
representative and i'd like to add
representative groter that on the house
website you can find statutory and study
committees this is a statutory committee
thank you may i ask my question
thank you madam chair
and thank you mike for taking my
question i asked senator sherman earlier
about tools available to physicians who
might be interested in the cost of the
therapies that they are prescribing and
we both lamented the lack of such tools
to to individual physicians are you
aware of any tools that would allow
physicians to do as representative
fellows said earlier uh to basically
help their patients in making these
decisions that neither i nor senator
sherman were aware of thank you for the
question i'm not aware and i i do know
in in my conversations with speaking
with our council and our legislative
committee that was one of their
frustrations uh is not having some of
those resources available to them and um
i think that's one of the reasons why
they really see a benefit in this board
and having something that can uh maybe
establish a model for for them moving
forward
i i thank you
all right seeing none thank you for your
testimony
madam chair and members of the committee
my name is holly stevens and i am the
director of public policy at nami new
hampshire the national alliance on
nami new hampshire is a non-profit
nonpartisan grassroots organization
whose mission is to improve the lives of
all people impacted by mental illness
and suicide through support education
and advocacy on behalf of nami new
hampshire i am here today to speak in
that excuse me
ms stevens we do have your written
testimony
and
you don't need to read it to us could
you just give us the highlights
yes thank you madam chair um
this is a new position for me so i'm
still trying to learn the uh the
my jargon for the the beginning
i could probably rattle my new futures
off um pretty easily um so i apologize i
was reading the first paragraph
um
you know par my my testimony does start
off with the quote of the the governor
which you've heard already
you know a couple things that i just did
want to highlight you've heard a lot
about
one of the main functions of the board
which is
looking at the public payers
in the state
another thing that this
board would be able to do is is look at
encouraging those public payers to
possibly come together
and
have one formulary right now
the retirees have one formulary
the state employees have one formulary
the
the city employees in manchester have
yet another formulary same thing in
nashua
same thing in claremont um you know
and
what this would do would allow
this board to take a look at that
information and see if it makes sense to
have a statewide formulary that all of
the public payers can use
and can you because they can do
excuse me they could possibly do bulk
buying of drugs altogether
so you don't have manchester buying
drugs in nashua you've got them all
together it's a bigger pool you can
negotiate
uh for for better prices with the drug
manufacturers so that's another thing
that
we haven't heard today that this board
would be able to look at and recommend
another thing too is that small
businesses
see if maybe
they wanted to buy this formulary
because if you look through the statute
there is a provision
that would allow small businesses to be
able to buy into so that would help so a
lot of our small businesses that are
struggling to even provide health
insurance
because of the cost if they would be
able to buy into a state formulary
that is a lot cheaper they might be able
to afford
health insurance for
their employees
and then the second
is to is to gather the information but
specifically and i apologize i just need
to to read exactly what they need to do
they
have to gather information
on
the costliest
drugs in the state
the most prescribed drugs in the state
and the medications with the highest
year over year increases
and they have to report out on that so
that everybody in new hampshire
knows what those are it's the 25
costliest the 25 most prescribed and the
25 with increases year over year
you know just having that information
and just having that transparency one
can sometimes put downward pressure on
the manufacturers because they have to
report it but secondly
it does allow
um
for the state
to look and see if there's anything that
can be done
to try to get a hold of
these prescription drug prices for
instance also in house bill 1280 was the
copay cap on insulin
if you remember
that was one drug that was pulled out
because it was very costly and the
increases kept going year over year over
year
so
you folks decided that enough was enough
and
people weren't going to have to pay that
anymore so this information can allow
you to to look at that on paper and say
okay
you know what do i need to do for my
constituents in order to make this more
and i think with that i will just end my
testimony and if you have any questions
i'm more than happy to take them i did
include
with my testimony three pieces of
testimony from
folks that are
nami new hampshire advocates on their
experience with high cost of drugs
thank you very much for that
is there any questions
representative marsh
thank you madam chair thank you holly
for taking my question first of all
congratulations on your new position
it's a pleasure to see you again you've
got very big shoes to fill um it's my
understanding that drugs used in
behavioral health who are the people
that you represent now
are particularly expensive for some of
these patients particularly in relation
to their income uh would you like to
speak to us for a moment as to the
consequences to these patients when they
cannot afford or are forced to ration
the drugs that they are used needing to
use for treating their excuse me
representative marsh i don't believe
that's exactly
i i beg to differ because if we
since most of the people that she
represents are actually insured under
the state health insurance plans
including the three medicaid plans uh
therefore they're not being able to
obtain their drugs as exceedingly
relevant uh to
repealing the prescription drug
affordability board which is uh trying
to make those drugs less expensive to
those very payers i don't think it's
actually relevant
and also it's 4 3 it's 4 20
and it's been a very long day i don't
think it's relevant or useful we can all
agree that lower prescription drugs
prices for people would be a good thing
the question we're debating is is this a
any other questions
i have a question madam chair is this
going to a subcommittee or are we go
representative schmidt i'm afraid that
it will not be going to a subcommittee
because it's an early bill we have to
vote it out
and have the report in no later than
this thursday
any other questions seeing none i'll
good afternoon madam chair committee
members
i am todd fahey the state director of
aarp new hampshire
they appear today on behalf of aarp new
hampshire and as an advocate for that
organization
i also serve on the prescription drug
affordability board as the governor's
appointee to it
so
but i uh will defer to uh my colleagues
on the board who spoke mostly to it
although i'll entertain whatever
questions you would like to ask me
so
the cost of prescription drugs
in the nation and in new hampshire
as i sit here
surely our friends and neighbors your
constituents
are having to decide
whether they're going to be able to pay
for their meds
or
they will have to um or pay for their
utilities
or their food
that's a reality
we did a survey
statistically significant survey in 2020
of
45 plus granite staters
across the political spectrum from the
left to the right
um 45 years old plus
85 percent of them and i'm happy to
share that survey
said
that this was extremely or very
important to them to deal with the
escalating cost of prescription drug
prices
i was absolutely
so proud of the work that this
legislature did
by way of concurrence omnibus bill or
otherwise
in 2020 in the midst of a pandemic you
all saw fit
to bring a needed transparency to an
industry that has operated without
transparency for years
and now
and i understand the reasoning and i
respect the reasoning in the thinking
of our elected officials
but now in one motion
in hours and hours of work
we're on the precipice of of
abolishing the board
not trying to fix it mind you
the board does not act in secrecy
i've sat on every board meeting some in
person some virtually since it began
we have heard from the pharmaceutical
industry
from pharmacy benefit managers from
experts in the fields all of it's public
we're administratively attached to the
department of health and human services
i would encourage you to go watch if
you'd like
everything has been
the biggest fear i have on this board in
all honesty
and i am a lawyer 21 years of experience
in new hampshire and i'm also a granite
stater i grew up here was born here
proud of it
is the the requirement to safeguard the
this confidential information produced
to the board
if that leaks out
i don't want to even be able to have to
touch that information and somehow get
sued by the pharmaceutical industry for
disclosing proprietary information
there's very very very strong
requirements to maintain confidentiality
so
the idea that we would in any way be uh
cavalier or loose with confidential
information
i think frankly as a board member the
board itself by the statute and
individual members would be held liable
and i can imagine that would be a pretty
severe
consequence
i'm recognizing the time is short so
i'll wrap
year over year
prescription drug prices have increased
every year and now we're in an
inflationary environment where what was
maybe worse before and was worse before
is infinitely worse now
for our fellow granite staters who are
depending upon
this group
this board and frankly this body
to stand with them
if you abolish this board
you are abolishing perhaps the best
opportunity for transparency that we've
seen
in new hampshire to understand
prescription drug pricing
we do have commerce clause issues here
we're not going to be
fixing prices
we're not going to be selling
proprietary information surely i
wouldn't do it i don't want to be
selling information from merck
pharmaceuticals or any other and then
have to explain myself
but i think one of the i think
representative scitech asked a question
how do you know
how do you know if you've done anything
worthwhile at the end of the day here's
what i'll tell you a front page headline
showing the the the findings of the
board
explaining to the public by way of
public report the following information
about prescription drugs both brand name
and generic the 25 most frequently
prescribed drugs in the state the 25
costliest drugs as determined by the
total amount spent on those drugs in the
state by public payers the state of new
hampshire and political subdivisions
thereof
and the 25 drugs with the highest
year-over-year cost increases as
determined by the total amount spent on
those drugs in the state would we not
want to know that we're so smart here in
the granite state
i was so proud of what we did in a
bipartisan way of 2020 i'm imploring you
with all due respect for those who
disagree with our position
to to
maintain this board vote down this
amendment
thank you madam chair
thank you very much are there any
yes representative horrigan thank you
very much and uh thanks for your
testimony my membership fee
the fraction of a penny that's my
membership fee was well spent um
my question is um is there anything we
can learn from the rollout of the
vaccines which i'm sure are difficult to
manufacture and very expensive developed
just like
not it's not as simple as it should be
but we developed a relatively uh simple
mechanism for distributing them and
they've been available to free to anyone
who who wants it so why
is there anything we can learn from that
and change the way we distribute other
thank you for the question
representative horrigan
i'm not sure i i think that the rollout
of the the vaccines that's uh that's a
tough question i mean we're obviously a
very divided nation over whether we even
like the vaccines um certainly in new
hampshire um
i i guess i would say
the focus here is on uh affordability
representative so i don't know if there
are direct lessons to be learned and if
thank you are there other questions from
the committee
all right seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you madam chair
committee members i don't have any more
cards is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
okay seeing none i'm going to close the
public hearing thank you all for your
test
and i think i would ask everyone else to
leave the room because we're going to
have a republican caucus for about
okay quarter of
questions
thank you i think we're all here except
okay well that won't take her too too
long to come back
all right we have two two bills early
bills that we need to vote out of
committee
so
rep i'm going to to move ought to pass
for house bill
okay
this is a there's copies available on
the table
it's a minor update of the amendment
that i discussed with the subcommittee
and then had earlier representative
scitec caught a typo
and so we had to get a new amendment but
right
the
the amendment leaves the
cost of living adjustment
at one and a half percent on
july 1st 2022 for people who have been
retired for five years
and on the first thirty thousand of
their re of their pension
so that's left that's there
representative rhodes
you might mention that their
subcommittee was unanimous yes the
subcommittee agreed on this
in principle unanimously
i'm just describing what it is for the
rest of the committee
it
then eliminates
the
unrestrained
annual cost of living increases by the
retirement system which would cost
approximately two billion dollars
because the subcommittee thought that
was a bit
much it also puts the cost of the
this
into the retirement fund as a lump sum
paying for the whole whole cost of
it from this year's general fund
and that is the way we used to do
cost of living increases when we were
as conditions warranted we would say
okay we can afford for a cost of living
increase here's the money for it and put
it in the retirement system to pay for
it forever
we didn't take out a 20-year mortgage
which is what we did in 19 when we get
granted a cost of living increase
in doing that with one hand while we
have people complain about their
property taxes
seems
ridiculous to me but i'll let you make
your own judgment on it in any event
this grants a cost of living increase
one time
and pays for it and that's makes
what it does
representative rhodes do you wish to
speak to yourself
no thank you madam chair you covered it
okay
are there any other questions comments
speeches
i'm sorry
yes sir
the motion is ought to pass amendment
zero five five one h to house bill 1535
representative rhodes yes
the clerk verts yes representative
pearson yes
representative jacobovich yes
representative lekkis yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey
yes
representative lonzaro yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
yes
representative short
representative schmidt aye
representative marsh yes
representative fellows
yes
representative
gamorlo yes
sorry
representative grota
yes representative o'brien yes and the
chair
the amendment passes 19-0
and i move ought to pass with amendment
on house bill 1535
okay seconded by representative pierce
pearson
and i have nothing to say
present pearson
i got a lot to say
but i'm not going to say it here
the
just a just a quick reminder you know
one of the things that um
[Music]
we to you know we have a responsibility
of here at the state is to
you know take care of of those that we
were
we stewarded through their careers
helping uh the citizens of the state and
you know the the the
the way we're going about doing this
here is the most prudent one in the in
the time that we have i think when the
system becomes more more healthy we can
look at other
other ways to handle our cost of living
look at
and uh
but certainly um
you know
when the budget is has the surplus that
it does and in the uh
certain
uh inflationary
strains that retirees are feeling right
now i think this is uh
this is prudent it's fair
it's uh frankly it's it's only about 450
bucks per person so it's their medical
uh expenses are gonna
suck that up real fast but
um you know this is this is the way that
it should be done in in uh where it
doesn't
increase the unfunded liability it
doesn't get downshifted we just we
handle it and take care of it as a
legislature um
all at once so this is this is the good
formula i like it and i encourage all of
any other comments representative
schmidt
amen
thank you representative schmidt any
exactly
thank you all other questions comments
in that case the motion is ought to pass
with amendment on house bill 1535 and
the clerk can call the rule
rep
representative rhodes yes
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson yes representative yakovich
yes
representative electus yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
no
representative alenzara yes
representative santo anastasia no
representative goalie
yes
representative schuett
yes representative horrigan yes
representative schmidt
aye
that was pretty short too representative
marsh yes
representative fellows
yes
representative of gamarlo
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes the chair
okay the motion passes 17 to 2 it's not
suitable for consent even if it were
unanimous so it'll be on the regular
calendar
thank you i'll get the blurb in this
tonight
yes
yes i made the motion i've written the
blurb already and i'll be sending it in
okay then we have
house bill
representative allegro you have a motion
yes i would like to move hb 1566 to
interim study
is there a second
i'll second that
okay
i'm sorry madam chair is it to the is
the
motion to move the bill to interim study
allegra
well after that hearing we have an awful
lot to digest and if there was ever a
bill
that required interim study i think this
is the one
also i believe there's um
still some debate and uncertainty
things to be hashed out over the
prescription drug affordability
board and i think it was that that part
of the debate would benefit as well
representative pearson
thank you madam chair
i agree with representative allegro
there was there was a lot going on here
and
i think that you know the
the intent here of this board is good
the the idea is good it's it's a it's
the largest
stressor and strain on our retirees
and
i think um
you know
taking a scalpel to this and and digging
deep and and tweaking some things and
looking at
at this at the interim study level is
appropriate
um
rather than just
you know the the machete approach so
i think this is this is a
a clear case of interim studies being
necessary and uh
and i hope you don't put me on it thank
you
ah thank you i love the heartfelt
enthusiasm representative schmidt you
had a question or comment
i do madam chair so
uh let the record reflect uh for the
first time maybe ever i
say amen to representative allegro's
remarks uh because this is a heavy lift
and
we've got to get the facts straight for
and know what we're talking about before
we vote this out thank you
thank you i i agree with you myself it
the the bill had
a number of issues and i'm certainly not
willing to pass it but it deserves
another look representative rhodes and
then goalie
as far as interim study i i really hope
i'm not on the on the study committee
because
as far as is navigating this ship i i
don't know that this really belongs even
in our wheelhouse i understand it does
it says board but
i feel like i'm i've drowned at the
bottom of the wave pool and i
i just don't don't know that we that our
group of people is some of the great
things that we've we've been able to
pass out of this committee together if
this is one of them that that we should
be the ones discussing so
um please
don't thank you
thank you madam chair and i was
just had my thunder stole from me about
my concern as to
this being the appropriate committee to
interim study this um
looking back at where the bill came from
commerce
and
it seems like it's more of their purview
than it would be for us um i know
listening to all the details i think
maybe one of the few people here that
understands it is representative marsh
but i was getting lost in
all the weeds as to what was going on
i'm not sure
what i'm going to do but i
i worry about interim study
it sounds like the board's in place in
doing what they want and a lot of
organizations that are following them
seem to think they're doing the
appropriate thing
going forward
they were here today testifying in favor
so i'm
inclined to support those organizations
and continue this board going forward
thank you well interim study would not
interfere with the board there are they
it exists
it would continue
we couldn't e
we won't even pass legislation this year
it would be looking
we would be looking at the original bill
which was
their hiring authority and this position
they were trying to create
which is
something we understand we could just
assume
they're good we know what they want to
do they want to lower prices
they're the experts we're just looking
at their process and their organization
which is something we do know how to do
representative lackas thank you yeah i
still have some serious concerns about
the board but i'm i'm willing to accept
interim study because it is
even more complicated than
than i understood it to be
thanks
okay representative scitec
this is a very disturbing bill for me
because
nothing to do with the merits of it i
heard many people whom i respect
saying different things
i have 20 or 30 questions i'd like to
ask and i accept your thanks for not
asking them
but when i i don't want to get into the
particulars and i'm sure there's a way
that one will explain you
these people are all skilled but it just
there's some
thank you representative marsh and then
shut
thank you madam chair uh
this this uh i i think i can ultimately
vote for interim study because i believe
this will not end up being a true
interim study by this committee the
underlying bill is to fix some technical
issues with the board that the board
needs to move forward for instance
without approving the budget line they
can't collect the fees to pay the
director which they need to hire in
order to do their work
however i do understand that that
language will likely come back to us in
one form or another attached to some
other bill because i already know people
are talking about doing that
so i i think at the end of the day the
any interim study by this committee will
become moot
and therefore i can vote for a term
study today
you for that encouraging remark
representative schuett
thank you madam chair um
would it be proper madam chair if if
interim study is passed by the house
to at least invite members of the
commerce committee
or a group
to help us and i think that if we are
getting into the details of what the
board is doing we might want to invite
health and human services as well yes i
think that would be reasonable thank you
and and just one other comment i i would
um
remind representative rhodes that while
this bill may be looked at but at a
subcommittee in the long run our whole
committee does interim study
so she's not excused
we will all learn more about
prescription drug pricing than we really
want to know sorry about that guys i can
tell you the story of the slaughterhouse
bills we had 10 12 years ago
but i won't any other questions or
comments
representative schmidt
well i think probably a couple of us are
on medicare already in this committee
but as somebody who's been on medicare
for a long time it's nice to having to
have the medicare a stamp of uh
non-approval of the amount i'm billed
for on virtually everything i'm also on
medicare part d and and
so uh i'm having the big hitters
do my drug pricing negotiation and it's
uh
you heard what what dr sherman said with
regard to how complex it is
so i'm glad i don't have to make that
that kind of a call every time
okay excellent any other comments
okay seeing none the motion is interim
study on house bill 1566
representative rhodes yes
clerk votes yes representative pearson
yes
representative jacobovich yes
representative lekkis yes representative
allegro
representative bailey
yes
representative lonzaro yes
representative santo nestaso
yes representative goalie yes
representative sheward
yes
representative horrigan yes
representative schmidt aye
representative marsh
yes
representative fellowes yes
representative gamarlo
yes
representative grota
yes representative o'brien
yes
and the chair
19 to 0.
okay the motion passes 19 to zero
we will interim study house bill 1566
well that's fine yes i understand that
the the leaders of the study committee
will have to be care carefully selected
among those who care
uh but we could
there's no reason not to put it on the
bill on interim study on consent
okay no objections
okay
thank you very much that is the work we
had to do today
and
i won't extend the tendency of people to
use the
language of sort of their heritage for
voting because in greek
nay means yes
thank you that will and that'll confuse
everybody
you